you
those on the committee i do have some
information for the committee but i will
pass all this information out when
everybody's here we have two
hearings that we're looking at this
morning prior to getting in the exact
sessions
the first bill which we're addressing is
1229 establishing a committee to study
school meal programs in new hampshire's
public schools and non-sectarian schools
that accept public
funds and i'd like to
recognize representative horgan the
thank you very much mr chairman thank
you very much to the
to the to the committee um h
i'm representing timothy horrigan from
the towns of
roughness stratfor county district six
which is the towns of durham and madbury
so it's two-thirds of the oyster river
cooperative school district
and so i'm here to introduce hb 1229
establishing a committee to study school
meal programs in new hampshire public
schools and non-sectarian schools that
actually went and uh so this bill is
exactly the same aside from the
expiration and effective dates as hb 203
which came before the house committee
last year and that in turn hb 203 in
terms exactly the same as hb 1681 is
amended by the house education committee
sent to house finance so it's had a
it should have
in 2020 the you know it passed through
the committee probably didn't even
probably didn't even need to be in house
finance but in all the confusion that
was back in february march 2020 so those
of you here remember that it was like a
rather chaotic time and uh
it's never even made through the floor
of the house and frankly last year you
you itled it and normally would have
been unable to bring it back this year
however thanks to moore
cove which created uh chaos um
the full house some as you all remember
never voted on hb 203 and many other
bills so we never actually voted on
any of the itl bills except for a few
that were either especially
controversial or where uh
where the uh where there was some hope
of overturning the itl and i would have
uh
and of course i'm asking you to change
your mind this year since you turned the
bill down uh last year but
i think uh this version of the bill
should in due course be passed it's just
a uh just a study committee
so if you pass this it'll meet this
summer and fall several times and
discuss uh
discuss uh the funding and maybe what
other issues the committee wants to
discuss about school meal programs
there's a lot
probably a lot to be discussed um one
thing that's happened since the covet
pandemic is uh
is um
is that uh when we have remote learning
i think most schools send school lunches
around to every house because there's uh
it was probably easier to do that
administratively there was funding
available to do that and also uh
that uh
that eliminated uh confidentiality
concerns and um
many probably like a mirror there's like
many other issues the committee could
discuss i think it'd be a good exercise
so uh
obviously you're not going to study
all aspects of this issue but i think
it's worth enough time to do some good
work so um even though
even though the majority turned it down
last time my since i was able to bring
it back again i decided to
take a few minutes and bring it back for
you again give you another chance to uh
to think about i hope this time you'll
see fit to pass it and um so i have the
uh then later this year the committee
could meet it would be
three members of the house and one
senator so it would not be a cumbersome
group it's just uh just four people so i
uh
so that's uh
that's so that's my bill i'll be happy
to answer any questions should you have
them thank you very much representative
horrigan are there any questions from
the committee
and it's not even a legal question
um
so i love this bill you know we are the
richest country in the world and my
belief is no child should ever be
sitting in school hungry yeah so i'm
wondering if you when you put this
together if you have any data
on how many kids are sitting there
hungry because they haven't had
breakfast or how many kids are sitting
there hungry because they haven't had
lunch
and i'm wondering if you have data in
the background that inspired this bill
um well i guess i don't the exact number
here but i know i know it's very
significant so and anybody who's worked
in
the education profession will tell you
the same thing so i remember
we had a
lot of you probably remember
representative sue ford who's on this
committee for many years she's a former
school principal and now she's talking
how she used to make sure every kid was
fed even that meant like feeding them
out of her own pocket so it's uh
i know it's
offhand i'd say it's about 25 to
percent but um i
yes i
that's probably one reason we need the
committee in order to nail down the
exact number but yes so follow up
yes
so i heard an interesting story or read
i think i heard it on the radio i get so
much news sometimes i'm not sure where
it comes from
about
a family that had chosen to go remote
because of cobit and they had asthma in
the house and they did not have
appropriate covert protocols in the
school so they kept their kids home and
it turns out that by going remote and
using a velox kind of thing on a remote
you lose your qualification for free and
reduced school lunch and i didn't
obviously that would be something this
committee can can study i didn't know if
you had come across those kinds of
stories as well no that's a um
well that's i had not come across that
story but that's certainly uh i was like
frankly
shocked
i don't know the details of course but
frankly that's some i'm pretty sure i'd
be shocked by the details if i uh if i
heard them themselves like that's uh
that's certainly uh something that the
community could look into also one
specific thing which was a problem even
before the pandemic even more so now is
that there's a large
number of families who are eligible for
the reduced-price meals but for whatever
reason because they don't think they
deserve it or they think the application
process is too
cumbersome or whatever choose not to
apply even though they could
they could get it and that's like not
good for either the school district or
the family because the school district
uh
gets less aid
gets less aid when um their reduced
price or free meal
eligible students aren't are being under
counted and then of course the families
are
paying more for their lunch than they
should be and i actually frankly i think
in the perfect world every family every
kid in school should probably get the
free lunch as part of their you know
that should be an integral part of their
school day and they shouldn't have to
pay extra for it but that's uh
i mean i may be a dreamer or that may be
realistic um
it certainly uh they did manage to do it
at least in my school district and many
others uh you know
now two years ago seems like about 20
but
two years ago in 2020 when they had to
shut down the schools rather abruptly
further questions represent woodcock
thank you chairman good morning
representative uh just a couple quick
ones and a short story but
uh as i look at this bill and and the
the multiple bills you brought in on
food and hunger nutrition for youngsters
uh this past session uh is every every
bill has a goal somewhere yes um so in
the focus of this committee are you
looking for us to if it passes to look
more at the nutritional piece or more at
the participation piece
well well both and i think also in
addition to the nutrition probably kids
should be taught more about
more about food than they are so that's
just you know just from the
uh there should be more it should be
more emphasis in the health curriculum
on your food and they probably should
know more about how food is raised and
how it's prepared that um
so i remember there seems to be less of
that in uh in
schools today than it was when i was a
kid and even then we you know we didn't
really
learn as much as we should have about it
but
further question yes well mini story
thank you
just to follow up in your your
participation rate piece as as a former
high school
uh person to supervise the cafeteria as
my favorite part of the day um i often
saw that the high schoolers who had
siblings in the younger levels in
elementary middle school did not
participate
uh because it wasn't cool and they
didn't in their in their family yeah so
it it as a media you're proposing for
the committee wouldn't it be nice if the
family qualifies
it's covered for all the siblings uh
because the high school kids really
don't uh if they're the same family
because of that that
stereotype and no matter no matter what
you try to do with the the cars and the
anonymity is still there but i
appreciate you bringing this forward for
this review thank you thank you thank
you chairman
further questions of representative
horrigan
not seeing any thank you very much good
i've got some written testimonies so i
guess i'll pass it around the table but
um thank you
so uh hopefully hopefully the third time
will be the or the fourth time will be
the charm for this thanks are there any
other pink cards for this uh bill
nazi thank you very much i will close
for me 12 45
aaron is checking on
well the uh we're in this break here and
we start the next bill up 9 45 some
announcements can be given here
um
one i do have these uh sheets available
for everybody in the community to be
tracking the various bills which we have
it's an abbreviated form which will help
us
obviously you don't see the action
taking place on any of this because that
won't occur until it's in the docket
nothing's in the dock yet so we'll hand
these out
i'll pass them around for
either way for members on the committee
to have so you can also be tracking
these bills
and looking at
the days which we are looking for our
break
i am
looking at let me first give you the
days that we're going to have to do
the
next week
we will be meeting here
on the
15th
that's a tuesday
and the 15th is already scheduled in the
calendar it's for those bills which came
from the fourth
and we're moved to the fifth that was
the snow day
so it's the same order same you know
time frames for all the bills on the
15th
the 16th is a half day in manchester
uh so we're for full session so
obviously we're not meeting here
and the same on the 17th which is also a
session day in manchester that all that
information is in the in the blue
calendar
to be scheduled and that's it's going to
come out in the calendar
uh we will be meeting on the 22nd
the 23rd
and the 24th to exec bills
so that's tuesday wednesday and thursday
uh you'll notice in the calendar there's
only going to be one bill listed to exec
but below it will say other bills you
know can be exact we don't want to have
to start listing
every bill in the world
um
and and if you if you for example list a
bill for being heard on the 24th
but you have a whole available on the
22nd or 23rd you can't exact that bill
because it's already been identified
later on
so
i think the best way to do it is i'll
just list one bill for the 22nd the 23rd
and the 24th and we'll work together as
we have been and trying to identify
which ones we're looking at in
coming up just like we've done this week
and the previous week
we do have
two bills which we have to have hearings
on
those were the bills which were the mass
bills which were removed from the dock
because we couldn't find the general
we couldn't go down the finance room
that was taken and and our our hall was
also being used at that day
by another committee
so i'm looking potentially for doing
those bills on the morning of the 25th
that's the friday and having it done and
then we won't be doing any executing
other than those those three bills and
and there is another bill which there's
an amendment coming forward on
11 41. the three bills which the two
bills which we had scheduled which we
had to
put off because of snow
or because of the crowdedness i mean 11
31 and 1371
there is an amendment coming up for 11
41. i i feel that's not really
it's changing that bill around too much
so we need to have a hearing on it
and and uh that will be held also on
that same day so we will be doing in the
25th
and then and we won't be doing any
executing on anything else other than
yes
those three those three bills on the
first two three days dimension on the
tuesday wednesday thursday it will be
exacting as i've mentioned
then looking at
we'll work together we'll we'll continue
working like we're working
then going on into the next week the
week of the 28th that's the week that
i'm not scheduling anything it'll be a
i have uh
uh trustee meetings with the university
system all day and the third and the
fourth so i wouldn't be here for those
anyways
um
but so the 28th if you have to make book
a reservation or something i know it's
late to be booking now but that's you
know we've been trying to do the best we
can and figure out
uh what holes we might have
then uh going on forward
we're going to have to have available
the
seventh eighth ninth and the half day on
the 10th for exacting quite possibly
um
so
if we take that break it means we're
going to have approximately seven and a
half days to execute the bills which we
have left and that's probably about uh
three-quarters of the bills that we have
left after today it may be less than
that
so we may not need it but
we have those days available to to
really capture everything yes
how many bills do we have left to here
we have the uh bills which were doing on
the 15th which were the carryover from
the fourth right then we had those three
bills
um that i just alluded to
11 31 1371 and 11 41. that's it that's
it we're done
we've heard here
thank you you know other than what we're
doing today
you know we have another one coming up
here at 12 22 which we haven't heard yet
either
and that's an early bill
so
so we could quite possibly be you know
we will probably be executing that bill
along with everything else today
um we could even do it right after
depending upon how fast we get through
yeah there there's um
yes yes that's correct
so that's that's where we are on
on uh our scheduling our calendar i just
want everybody to realize that the 28th
you know
okay um
so we have now a break of about 20
minutes here
which we will take as a break
and
be ready to go at uh
did everybody get a copy of the flow
chart
okay
relation
whose name is
noble blood
so when i made that flip up it was
perfect
um
okay
well i don't know what i did with my
is
uh
so did you get groceries
bills
okay
go ahead representative ford
thank you mr chair thank you
committee members fellow committee
members
i have circulated to you the statement
that i submitted to ols
and for this bill
and it speaks much more clearly to the
intent of the bill than the bill finally
emerged from the machinery
as a legal
sort of bill
and uh i would ask you to to read that
so i i'm not going to repeat it all to
you except to say that
the intent of this bill is to protect
the academic integrity
of the process of education
as well as to protect the student
from being abused by people whose
self-interests
are
somehow thought better
than the students welfare
i have experienced this in several
states
i have not experienced it in new
hampshire
and some people think well if it hasn't
happened here
why what do you want a bill
to prevent it from happening here
in one word
i had a classmate in college who could
completed every cl course the student
university had at the 100 level
and then he got in his red corvette and
that's not why we have universities
we're not a training ground for
professional sports
this is to educate people for a fruitful
life
and anybody who interferes with that
might as well be breaking one of their
arms or something else in an academic or
intellectual sense because they're
denying them the education
which will provide their livelihood
throughout their life
it's like theft
i was in the office one day when one of
my office mates was talking to an
assistant coach
and all of a sudden there was an uproar
and she picked up her book bag
and began beating the man about the head
and shoulders and chased him out of the
building using language i never heard
why
he had she he had asked her to change
the grade of a student athlete
so that he would remain eligible to play
sports
apparently not aware that her own
husband
worked at a local roadhouse as a
bartender because he had never completed
his degree
it's that kind of travesty that should
not occur
and yet someone who i don't know for
whatever personal reasons maybe just an
art and booster of the home team
to put it most polite face on it
will say to a student
oh maybe we can work out a summer job
for you or something but you need to
concentrate on football
i was told recently in new hampshire by
a man who had played ball out of state
gone on to a pro career and then
terminated it
that the coach at st norbert said
i know the
orientation people tell you you're here
to work on your uh when you're on campus
you should focus on academics but i'm
here to tell you when you're on campus
do we want people saying that to our
students in new hampshire
i mean football is fun and all that but
it's not why we send our kids to college
and that's why this bill is here
it's a preventive field
i don't know anyone who's done it i
can't point and say this person did that
no i can't
but i can't point you i know i had to
fire an athletic director and and
of coach
for taking a letter that i had to sign
offering admission to football players
and they wrote across the top of the
letter after they got it back with my
signature
don't worry about this housing business
and that was not part of our agreement
we were not that kind of a team
they were plainly lying to the students
and the rumor had it and they could
never prove it but they were telling the
students in the middle of a minnesota
winter
oh really
is that what you want to be in the
i don't think so
questions thank you are there questions
for our representative yes
thank you uh representative four you
have the penalty for this to be a felony
which is a pretty high bar felonies are
usually reserved for
extreme violent crimes murder
you know even assault those kinds of
things
and what made you decide to go for a
felony it's also by i might add
something that really is a kind of a
heavy duty lift for the prosecutors in
the courts so there's a significant cost
to this and any case that may be brought
again i'm wondering why a felony
my legal background is limited i have
represented clients in felony courses in
the military court system
and i won even with a signed confession
so
i know how serious that is
it's exactly the seriousness of it that
i want to convey how important it is it
perhaps is overstated there was some
back and forth about should it be a
felony or not and i said i just think it
ought to be something that makes people
say oh i'm not going to do that if i'm
going to have to pay 50 fine well well
maybe i'll do that
and i that was that was the intent it
may be overstated and it certainly
would welcome a
an amendment if that would
yes
are you aware that a class a misdemeanor
has a year imprisonment associate or can
have a year imprisonment associated with
it so no i'm not so even a cl even a
misdemeanor could potentially put
somebody in jail for this i'm wondering
if you would find that to be enough
about oh yes oh yes i i i stand
ready to and welcoming for
all meaningful kinds of adjustments like
that
thank you
thank you and thank you for taking my
question um in our code of conduct
book that
was developed here in new hampshire
in
principle 3 on page 14
and principle 3 is
responsibility to the school community
it says in fulfilling the
responsibilities to the school community
a credential holder
shall communicate responsibly
among members of the school community
while maintaining appropriate
professional boundaries
and part four that is
intentional uh prohibited
uh
let's see unprofessional conduct shall
include but not be limited to in section
four is intentionally altering or
misrepresenting student assessments
assessment results or official school
records
and this code of conduct can result in a
teacher losing their credentials
um i don't know if you're aware or not
but
at least in the public schools and i'm
not speaking at college because that's
kind of your purview but in the public
schools
grading is pretty much a local issue
grades and
and
the competencies are made at the local
level
uh teachers are the people who are
responsible for
giving an appropriate grade to the
appropriate uh
you know testing results or their their
participation or whatever
and i understand
i underst i totally understand
the frustration and the
perhaps anger
at athletes that um or coaches i i'd say
more coaches that try to get favor for
their their athletes
what i've seen and i guess this is a
would you believe what i've seen more is
that coaches will go to teachers where a
student is not doing well and ask what
can they do to help this student get a
better grade
and it used to be that the nhiaa the new
hampshire interscholastic athletic
association
had a standard that students had to be
passing
a certain number of courses in order to
participate on class on sports teams and
that's been waived a little bit for
homeschoolers
because they don't
have like four classes to to do it but
i'm i'm thinking
uh again i was going to ask you the same
question that uh representative walsh
asked you that don't you think that
felony is like
just not even a
hammer instead of a flyswatter it's like
a sledgehammer um i think it's really
uh something that maybe
maybe you can reconsider and i think
you've already answered that but i'll
ask it again without that i was not
aware of that handbook but i would ask
you um
what's the real penalty and if if it
doesn't convey with the idea that if you
do this you will be fired
you know that's sort of the the thing
that i'm going to say that the teacher
has some protection
and going and saying this person
approached me and asked me to change the
game because what does the teacher have
if
some major benefactor or whatever sidles
up to them and said boy it would really
help if he had a passing grade and
what does the teacher do
i mean they're caught in a bind
and and maybe this is a person who can
affect the university in some
significant way
and so that's what i'm trying to do is
protect teachers and students to keep
that decision entirely to them in k-12
of course you have to involve the
parents
thank you but that that's where i'm
coming from amendments that make this
better and acknowledge that no problem
at all
i welcome
woodcock
thank you chairman
ford thank you so much for taking my
question i
um i was had the opportunity to briefly
read the uh the missives that you passed
out before the meeting and i i wonder if
you have it in front of you
i like you in front of you the
document you passed out
i know you have one okay if i may i'd
like you to turn to the last paragraph
of the last second page
i have i have no question about your
intent to maintain
athletic integrity uh at the high school
and the college level
my concern is particularly a concern is
the
the uh
realistic uh applicability uh in high
school in particular in new hampshire
uh
where we have you're talking about the
last sentence talked about allowing
coaches to be the primary instructors on
for years and years and years we've
asked for schools to create teacher
coaches teacher coaches teacher coaches
so they can look for the well-being of
youngsters oversee them uh make sure
that they're in school give them all
those types of motivations not to negate
their grades but to do that uh
and then we've lost part of that over
the years because there's no stipends
there's too much work yeah yeah and now
we never know what we get
but
every once in a while we get a great one
a teacher coach and i'm thinking
particularly in the school where i come
from where i used to work
we have one of our
best mathematics teachers superb
teaches all our high level mathematic
classes the probability of statistics
the trigger the big stuff safety classes
he happens to be one of our athletic
coaches and he's been there a long time
and and
by this this
last sentence saying that if you can't
be a you shouldn't have him as a primary
instructor throughout the athletes
program of studies our options are we
take a superb human being a coach
and stop that or we take a youngster
who's trying to get advanced mathematics
and the school is limited and stop that
i mean i find this as a as as um
a problem
in terms of of this proposed bill and
your testimony
that that part particularly concerns me
that's an interesting situation to be in
and i commend the school for its good
fortune
i've not experienced that i've
experienced like in my own high school
uh where i went to our second largest
high school in louisiana
and
one coach taught all athletes
mathematics
now there's something
statistically impossible about that
equation
and the only reason it was
i'm sure
it wasn't said
but
they went to somebody who was
sympathetic with the athletics
ability to stay or athlete's ability to
stay eligible and had him teach the
courts it's in his self-interest
that they passed and that's an
impossible teach situation to put a
teacher in
follow up chairman laughing mate yes
okay
um
and let me give you another for instance
in in our teacher coaching scenario and
i understand and
i think there's a significant difference
between
the uh collegiate level and the high
school level in terms of eligibility and
and and that that type of influence
clearly there aren't any benefactors
that uh you know growth and high uh
spending thousands of dollars so a
youngster could play a ball on one of
those things but i just i'm looking here
at
a teacher coach in the school made you
as uh representative tan i was talking
about and i know when i was uh doing
that as a teacher coach
i would have my student athletes take a
wander a weekly or two weekly report for
each class the teachers sign up how
they're doing or they're there
not at the chance for the teacher to say
oh these guys are playing ball or this
but rather to make sure that this young
stuff it continues to continue to
participate academically and not
fluffing off kind of things now i would
i would
think that under this particular bill uh
and as the intent that you had here some
could assume then that i was putting
pressure on that teacher by letting them
know that i'm having this youngster walk
and ask you to sign the sheet that
they're passing i mean that could be is
that possible
a reasonable
not reasonable it's possible
uh
as a principle
i would think you know you had plenty of
cover in that sense against an
accusation of that simply because you
organize a system to support the student
and make academic success that's that's
the kind of
reaction and structural uh consideration
i would like given to this issue is
first the impetus is is the athlete
perceive
proceeding reasonably toward graduation
and it is the intent first that the
student graduate and then that they play
sports behind
thank you thank you chairman i
appreciate it thank you very much
representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative
um
this does this bill is written to affect
elementary and secondary as well
and i'm wondering if in this scenario
what the ramifications might be
of a parent coming into a teacher
and asking the teacher to change the
grade
for whatever reason for their child
would the teacher need to report the
parent to the police
um in order for the
how would that work if the parent did it
would the parent face a felony charge
my how i i just oh i'm sorry that's okay
i thought you had
finished my apology
uh
my simple answer is no
because the parent has an interest but
when the parents ask the teacher to
change the grade
the teacher's response should be
that's an improper request to make
i will do everything i can to help your
student i'll work with a tutor or i'll
give him extra assignments or whatever
it might be
but i don't just change grades because
it's
in someone else's opinion
in the best interest of the students
this is my grade it means something
but if i read your bill correctly
because the parent had asked
that person who requests
this
needs to be
reported
and then the thing i handed out to you
it says the instructor under supervision
of an administrator and or counselor
the student and in a formal grade review
process the parents of a k-12 student
are the only persons who should be
involved in the final discussions of the
student's grade
that's what i put when i submitted this
for a bill
the parents have a right to say and yes
they might ask that you say look i
understand your concern my concern is
that the student finished the grade
knowing what the student needs to know
to go to the next grade
so let's work on improving his academic
performance
and not just changing the grade
representative ford i i have a would you
believe and i'm gonna follow up a little
bit where represent porter is right now
um as a school principal for all those
years
i've had to go through the process of
changing grades let would you believe
that we have teachers
that retire
teachers that leave the school system at
the end of the year to have a vacation
they may leave a little bit early yeah
um they may be sick and not there for
the closing days
and
grades sometimes have to be changed for
various reasons would you believe that
there are reasons that
go along i wrote down a few of them that
there's makeup work that comes in
there's a a teacher may have given an
incomplete
and all of a sudden in the the
alternative program the grades come in
and there's need for a change there
there may be a medical issue associated
a long-term medical issue associated
with the student the list is just
horrendous yes and there can be
mathematical errors in the inputting of
grades and we all do that
i understand so then the under this
though to change that grade
of the instructor who hasn't given
permission to change that grade
is oftentimes done in schools i've had
my guidance counselor do it i've had the
myself do it where it's necessary to
change that grade the transcript and
which is shoved off to college is going
to reflect something which is not
actuality there was something that
didn't come in that should be part of
that grade so would you believe by
entering in uh elementary and secondary
education this we're kind of mixing
apples and oranges
with something that
may or may not be happening even in our
higher education programs well
that came from an excess of zeal on my
part and you'll notice in the title
academic integrity and student
protection act i did not envision the
scenario you have just tried i agree you
need to it needs to be amended to
include administrative decisions to
award grades under the school's normal
processes
something as simple as that and i think
that would protect the people you're
talking about but yes that's a valid
reason to change a grade by someone
other than the instructor and i think it
should be provided protection under this
bill
thank you are there further questions
from the committee representative
moffitt thank you michelle thank you for
taking my question i went to kvc in to a
college basketball player and the
college basketball coach came to me and
he didn't ask me to change the grade to
a c plus he just explained that
this player would now be ineligible
would have to move out of the dorm and
would probably have to leave school so
could i just
re
revisit my grading formula and run the
numbers again
so
uh
looking at line 14 my question is would
he or i be guilty of you know
he tried to persuade me to revisit my
calculation of the student's grade
uh so would i having done what i did and
listen to him and ran the numbers again
would i be guilty of that class b felony
would i have been or he potentially
potentially and
what i would suggest is the way to
handle that sort of situation is to take
that problem back to someone in the
administration like your dean and say
this is an unintended consequence of
this is there any way we can
mitigate this without having to corrupt
thank you
representative nelson
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question is there any warning
in this thing or it's immediately the
coach is fired well i i figured that the
promulgation of it and put out there
should serve as a warning not to do it
most of the egregious offenders i've
encountered were either
overzealous
boosters of one sort or another and some
assistant coaches undoubtedly sent out
by the head coach
yes there should be i think a warning
but there should also be a promulgation
of it this is the law of the land now
don't do this
and notify people put it out there
discuss it say we're going to protect
the students academic integrity and the
teacher's right to or to award a grade
that was earned
i don't think you come down wrong when
you say that just when you
i would agree that the punishments that
came out in the bill are
probably too heavy thank you
further questions represent lakas
yeah i'm just looking at the language on
the definition of instructor
any full-time or part-time employee
working as a substitute or adjunct
teacher or administrator and i don't
know all of the proper titles of
people but
it seems like
and maybe i'm misunderstanding but it
just seems like that eliminates
professors or
i don't know
full tilt
instructor is a double meaning word it
is an academic rank in college but it's
also anyone who teaches
so it can mean both and perhaps i was
not as careful in delineating that
but it means that anybody who owes an
academic position the vulnerability of
many instructors is that they're
temporary they're part-time one semester
one year and
their concern of course is having worked
for next semester
so if they get into some kind of a haha
and they don't have any kind of backing
for it
you may find the coach saying we don't
want them on the faculty and coach has
tenure the coach makes more than the
president you know uh
so
so were you were
so you weren't intentionally limiting it
to them no it's just that that's the way
they wrote it for you i was inclusively
including them okay thank you
further questions from the committee
we have a card from tom cronin
university system new hampshire welcome
tom
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee tom cronin director of
government relations for uh the
university system thank you for the
opportunity to be here on house bill
1222.
uh so i think you know we certainly
appreciate understand uh where the
sponsor is coming from on this uh we you
know as institutions um you know we are
committed to honest fair clear grading
practices um
academic honesty is a core value for all
of our institute all of our institutions
as it should be that said we do have a
number of concerns with at least how the
bill is drafted i do appreciate
representative ford uh sharing the
couple page document of what he perhaps
submitted to legislative services that
maybe explains some of the concerns we
have but i thought i'd run through them
quickly and then of course be happy to
take any questions so certainly a topic
that's come up already uh the
sort of the definition about
uh
the activities that would violate this
law uh we're most concerned about the
use of the word persuade or otherwise
interfere
certainly we have a grading appeals
process that is at its core the goal of
that is to persuade someone that you did
uh better in the class than the person
graded you on um otherwise interfere is
obviously quite vague in terms of how
that could
be interpreted
um second just a question about
the way educational institution is
defined
public or elementary secondary et cetera
i guess our thought on that would be if
the legislature agreed with the
necessity of including this in the
criminal code that it really should
apply to all of the states colleges and
universities not just uh usnh and ccsnh
uh and i think our colleagues would
agree that academic honesty is equally
as important at their institutions as
well but i think they'd also share some
of our concerns uh with how the bill is
drafted
um
class b felony has already been
mentioned uh we agree that that appears
to be an incredibly punitive penalty uh
in this case we'd also point out that
for faculty under contract i think we'd
be concerned about some of the required
suspension and other language that's
included in the law and that would
probably be contrary to collectively
bargained discipline and grievance
procedures
and really i think finally
our question would just be is this
really necessary i think our
institutions have both cultures and
processes in place that dissuade this
behavior um and then have steps to
appropriately address it should there be
reports that need to be looked into and
i think that's why uh we should be proud
that this isn't an instance that has
happened at colleges universities in the
state um
so i think with that i would close and
would just be happy to answer any
questions
thank you very much are there questions
representative tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um if the student at the university
system is 18 or older
can the parents really be involved in
the grade discussion without the
student's permission
no it's certainly not without the
student's permission i will say there is
uh a process through the grading appeals
uh
framework that does allow students to uh
bring in an advisor to perhaps attest to
his or her work in the case of a
graduate student they're allowed to
bring in a member of the community who
may have worked with them so there are
actually other people outside of even
the framework that representative ford
presents in his couple page document
that at least in our appeals process are
allowed to be engaged in attempting to
persuade a faculty member to change a
grade
yes you may
i'm speaking more to the privacy the
student privacy that if a student
doesn't wish if they're 18 years or
older and they do not wish to have a
discussion about their grades
then the parents have
have
further question represent woodcock very
simple thank you uh thank you chairman
just a simple question do the do the
faculty in the university system have a
code of ethics that they follow yes
thank you thank you chamberlain
and i i'll follow that up code of ethics
and is there a policy which the
university system has to
address this type of a concern yes on
both for both the students it's in the
students rules rights and
responsibilities a pretty clear couple
page write-up and then on the faculty
side as well i mean ethics in teaching
and in scholarship are
required as part of uh
sort of those policies that govern
faculty work as well including up to you
know an obligation of everybody on the
campus to report issues that might seem
like they are crossing a line or nearing
a line to get clarity um
on
you know how this should be addressed is
somebody asking something they shouldn't
be asking and leading us at a path we
shouldn't be going
further questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you very much thank
are there any other pink cards for this
bill
okay uh we'll invite you up right now
my name's russ anne chester i'm from
bedford new hampshire but right now i am
coming to you as someone who spent
quite
almost the entire day yesterday when i
wasn't here i was in representative hall
they were talking about parents rights
and i heard testimony of over over
there was one that opposed putting a
parent's rights in place
and that was a representative for the
new hampshire
chapter of social workers
the only
what i did hear is over 75
parents voters and citizens in new
hampshire they were they all identified
as new hampshire citizens that said
that
there is a problem with our school
systems they have been
that that we need parental rights
and that we don't have
they ex there's policies and procedures
but those are being violated
excuse me this is not a parent rights
bill correct changing a grade
so
what i'm what i'm trying to get at is
this bill this bill says
um all schools
universities elementary schools middle
schools if anyone
has
has has coerced or changed a student's
grade then they there should be a
significant penalty for that that's the
reason why i support this bill is
because this bill is again about our
children and their rights and if their
if their rights are being violated
regardless of what age there should be
severe and swift consequences
but i just wanted to make you folks
aware that parents really are feeling
that they don't have a say in what's
happening in their school system
and this bill would
would put some responsibility on the
administration my opinion
that's all
are there any questions from the
committee
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
are there any other folks that like to
testify in this particular bill
i'm not saying we will close this
hearing
and we're going to be taking a break now
we're going to go into caucuses
so
and um
let's find a room for
test one two three test if it comes
fashion
you
okay uh i'd like to go ahead uh with the
committee right now we are
going into executive sessions
uh this this late this
morning and probably will continue after
lunch as well
um
unless we can really you know
have a miracle here
i i doubt
okay the first bill which we want to
take up and we're going to do our early
bills first and we're going to just walk
down chronologically and or not
chronologically numerically through the
numbers
and the first one is 1222.
that's a bill which we heard this
morning
thank you mr chairman
hb 1222 prohibiting coercion or
interference and grading and assessment
procedures in public schools colleges
and universities and i'll look to
chairman ladd for a motion i'd like to
make a motion on 1222 as itl
do i have a second
second
representative no seconds
um any
discussion um from the uh maker of the
motion possibly i'll be very brief we
did discuss this this morning
and
it incorporates elementary secondary and
higher education
and dealing with grading policy
i'm not going to go any further into the
what we discussed this morning everybody
was here they've heard it
so
um i i conclude from our discussion this
morning that um it the bill needs a lot
more work
and
it does not necessarily reflect the
intent of the
individual who made that made the bill
secondary wish to say anything uh sure
just briefly and um and uh we also heard
i think from uh from mr cronin with
respect to what the university system
has as far as
an appeals process for uh for grades as
well as
policies
and code of contact for both students
faculty and administration that that
also address a number of these issues
thank you thank you any further
discussion
see none
thank you this is regarding house bill
glenn
cordelli
yes
melissa litchfield is yes
ralph baume
representative lacus
representative moffitt
representative hobson
yes
representative ford
representative sony yes
representative nelson
representative luno
it's a motion of itl yes
what was out today sorry cornell is not
here today representative tanner yes
representative ellison yes
representative mullen yes
yes
representative woodcock yes
representative porter
yes
representative hall yes
okay
and representative
most important representative
most important but just yes
okay
so that vote is 18 to 0.
18-0
is consent fine with everybody
thank you very much uh so
going down i want to write that down
here
okay going on to the second bill uh
which would be um
hb 1516
hb 1516 is relative to the source of
i love to represent cordelli for a
motion
uh thank you mr chairman uh i would move
thank you very much
representative
uh discussion from the maker of the
motion
uh thank you mr chairman um
i think that there are um
issues with this bill
in terms of
the
[Music]
tax
property tax
revenues
i think it is um
a change to the
uh way that the
education freedom accounts
are appropriated
and
i do not think it is in the best
interest of the program or the children
thank you very much uh is there anything
from the
representative porter
thank you mr chair members of the
committee
i will be voting against the itl
i do believe that using local property
taxes to pay
for education at religious schools
is unconstitutional according to article
6 part 1 article 6 in the bill of rights
of the new hampshire constitution
i also believe that if we start using
locally raised property taxes to fund
these other programs it's a slippery
slope
and eventually property taxpayers will
be
burdened beyond belief um to keep all
these different and various
educational opportunities running for
everyone in the state so i urge you to
think carefully about what you're doing
here
with this bill
and i would like you to vote with me
please
thank you are there is there further
discussion yes represent
thank you very much mr chair uh i think
house bill 1516 simply protects
uh local property taxpayers from from um
from having
their money used
uh for these uh for these purposes and
uh it is it is simply about protecting
local property taxpayers
thank you further discussion
representative woodcock thank you
chairman ladd um i would concur on the
eye
on the uh
motion as representative porter was
suggesting
uh when this spill initially went
through the back duo we've been talking
about that it was going to be from ed
trust fund we've all continued here in
this state property tax property tax
property tax and we know that the bulk
of property tax is the schools
so least we can do is keep where we put
it initially so it doesn't go back to
local property taxes and continue to
increase the local taxpayers this is
this has the potential to slide in the
back door like some other bills do and
end up on the property tax bill
thank you thank you representative
tanner
thank you mr chair
um i'll be uh voting i
against this bill as well um
against the motion i'm sorry against the
motion um this is has the potential of
taking local tax dollars
out of the community
and spending it on
areas where there's uh
questionable accountability
and questionable accountability both
financially and academically
for the use of this
it also drains money local tax money
from
the
infrastructure that's built for
community schools as well so i will not
support this motion sorry thank you
representative waltz
i too will be voting no on the motion of
itl i believe this will raise local
property taxes and i think we're wrong
to be uh downshifting to the local
property taxes so i will vote no
thank you further discussion from
anybody here on the committee
not seeing any uh madam clerk would you
please call the rule
yes thank you this is regarding house
bill 1516
relative to the source of funds for efas
representative cordell
the motion is ito
you know i really thought that through
by the way before i spoke up
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
representative lacus
representative moffitt
yes
representative hopson yes
representative ford
yes representative sodi yes
representative nelson
representative luno no
representative waltz no
representative tanner no
ellison no
representative mullen no
representative woodcock no
representative porter no
and representative hall no
representative ladd yes
so the vote is 10
so there will be a minority report i'm
i'm
positive uh with ought to pass and who's
okay porter
now what we're asking it's going to help
uh
if you can get those done electronically
there they didn't give us any of the
handwritten forms we we have
a forum which is um
i think you've seen it they're not the
yellow and blue sheets
it's it's a form like this now
uh if you don't have a computer or that
use this but we would prefer if
everything came in electronically due to
the earliness of these bills and they
have to be in by tomorrow and it just
saves lindsay a lot of work down in the
office so could lindsay email that or um
jen email a copy of that document again
out to us just in case we've lost it
we get that done i don't see jen here
but we'll we'll
thanks we'll get it done yes that'd be
okay so the next bill which we have is
57 going in uh chronological order here
1657 establishes a new hampshire farm to
school reimbursement program
and i look to uh
represent bone for a recommendation or
motion i move itl on 1657.
is there any other
is there a second
repress i'll second thank you
representative do you care to speak to
the your motion yes as we heard from the
commissioner yesterday and
for the first time probably i've ever
agreed with him but anyway
we won't go there no
anyway yeah the thing is we don't live
in a except for a few items farm produce
is not available year round
also the initial cost
um the cost to do 600 000
uh it's
way
too much so
to me local school districts can can
already and they already do it contract
or buy produce from their local farms
and i don't think we need this bill
thank you
further discussion from represent lacus
just that the setup costs are so high in
the amount that each school is going to
get is so low that i don't think it's
going to be enough to encourage them to
start up or make that much difference so
we're going to go to this huge setup
cost and then not really do much with it
thank you
further discussion from the committee
representative luno
thank you very much mr chair so
we did hear from the uh from the
commissioner uh yesterday uh very a
little bit on this bill and i think his
his words were it's a great idea but it
needs more work
and i agree with uh with
with what he said and
it's a great idea it needs more work and
i think a motion of interim study would
actually be much more suitable
for for this bill
when we uh when we look at what we heard
from
for for testimony
it was uh it was extensive as far as as
far as how this would be
good for students good for nutrition and
good for new hampshire's um
agriculture
industry are the dollars huge no they're
not it's twelve hundred dollars per
school i think is the reimbursement
amount so given the fact that it is a
reimbursement program it's not quite
like what uh representative baum said
that that school districts can do this
already yes school districts can buy for
farms already but they don't get
reimbursed um and i think the
reimbursement rate is is a third of the
cost when uh when it comes from one of
the uh
the farms located here in new hampshire
it does have a um
a fiscal note
uh of six hundred thousand dollars in
appropriations uh to the department for
uh for reimbursing schools is that going
to change the uh the calculus when it
comes to any of these local new
hampshire farms probably not but um but
it's 600 thousand dollars in business
it's 600 000
that helps nutrition for um for school
kids and it's six hundred thousand
dollars that that actually will will
will probably result in um in a lot of
recognition about this program and
possibly even a greater understanding of
new hampshire's agricultural heritage so
for that reason i certainly can't
support an itl but i would cert i would
so i'll go ahead reps and like us
can we change the motion to interim
study no we have a motion on the table
thank you
um
i'd like to speak for a second um we
have another bill that we'll be
discussing that's not an early bill
which we are looking at interim study
uh dealing with meals
um
we are in a situation where this
committee has a huge number of bills
this year we're going into a summer
which is the summer which there's not
going to be a whole lot of studying
going on seeing that
a lot of people be campaigning
um
we we uh
there the intent of the bill there's
some really wonderful parts on the
commission would enlighten us that maybe
we'd be better even looking at a pilot
program where we can sprinkle a few more
dollars out to specific schools and and
and
try to see if this has some worth to it
there's also question what is local
and that was a question of stuff that's
grown in the state but taken out and
processed somewhere else and matched up
with a lot of other ingredients comes
back in is that local or not local
good question
but uh there's not going to stop us from
looking at and discussing this whole
topic when we got to the other bill like
when we get to this 12 29 a committee
for meal plans and all that
i we're talking about food
and
i just hesitate in getting too many
interim studies going we have a huge
interim study that we're going to come
up with dealing with how we fund
education in the state
and that's if we're going to do things
properly we've got to remember that
there's not a whole lot of us
uh to do what you know
we got to start consolidating and so
that's where i come from this
and rick and i agree with with
everything that you
you you said there and that that i
believe
this could be studied at the same time
we we
study interim studied
which is an informal study not a study
committee
study but an informal study
along with
um along with 1229. that's correct and
and um but but i think when when we take
a look at the hard itl on something that
from the commissioner says is a great
idea but it needs more work the itl i
think sends the wrong message
and um and and i don't think this
interim study would would compound
um or increase
what what this committee would uh would
probably do in that afternoon okay uh
represent bowman and represent tanner
yes whether or not we itl
study doesn't stop it from coming back
next year after people have worked on it
that's been done before so
i mean people can work on it if they
want and come up with suggestions and
come up with a bill next year whether or
not we itl or otp it or whatever i mean
next year starts a brand new
thank you rev santana
yes i i um represent the western part of
the state and we have a lot of small
family farms in that area not the big
aggie farms that
the commissioner was talking about might
be have have a hard time getting
involved with this program
i see a lot of merits to the policy of
this program and we're a policy
committee not a finance committee so
i i think the finance part of it
shouldn't be such a heavy burden on
making a decision um to go to interim
study where we actually have made a
commitment to these small family farms
into the schools to bring agriculture or
products into the school i think it's
different than than the other bills we
have on breakfast and and lunches
and how
long and how what's in them and that
sort of thing i think this is this is a
different program entirely we certainly
saw that there were a number of sponsors
on this bill and i think
that we would have no problem getting
a lot of help
in setting up a pilot program maybe as a
result of this interim study i think
waiting until next year is just kind of
kicking the can down the road a little
bit and
a lot of times things don't carry over
and i would hate to lose this bill so i
will be voting against
uh the motion and asking for an interim
study thank you thank you any further
discussion representative woodcock
thank you chairman lead
i also have concerns about this first
off it's one of our few
bipartisan bills we've seen this this uh
session and it's very bipartisan uh
former ed community member
representative allen and i have have for
three years now i had a bipartisan bill
upstairs in ag and as president boehm
said it keeps on getting these can
easily keep on getting kicked down the
road it's about time we uh go a little
bit more forward and commit to this uh
the local the local farm and the local
products what we're trying to do and and
it's a small number as representative
luna talked about the 1200 bucks for a
school maximum that's a maximum number
um and i agree with secretary casper
that it's that's a real
mile long an inch deep and may not
accomplish what we want
but as a pilot or the study so i i would
i would
sure
i would appreciate if the community in
this case would think more about the
possibility and not just kill it dead on
the floor with an idl particularly with
from the bipartisanship piece for a
change thank you
thank you further discussion
representative hall
thank you mr chair this bill is
close to the heart
grew up on the family farm we sold our
potatoes to the groston schools
and i think
this is an interim study absolutely we
should not be itling it
i think and this bill to me is about
farmers
rather than the other ones that are
about
more about the health and the nutrition
that the kids are getting so i i think
we really need to support our local
farmers
thank you further discussion represent
like us
so i'm
trying to figure out what the difference
between this
and representative ford's bill that we
itl because it wasn't ready
since it's a brand new year next year
and even if we interim study all we can
do is make a recommendation we can't
actually
it doesn't carry over so there's not
another you know a new bill would have
to be put in so
is this not something that we can just
say to the commissioner of ag and the
farms and
whoever else wants to work on this
get together and figure out how to do
this because i'm not sure that we
would be the ones to interim study it
anyways it seems like it's an
agricultural thing more than an
educational thing and so i'm not sure
that we're the right people to come up
with that recommendation
but i love the idea and i would love to
see it done
i'm just not sure we're the right ones
to do it
and i'm not sure that whatever we came
out of an interim study would be and
any more useful than what they might
come up with as a new bill next year and
either way it has to be a new bill next
year
we have a bill that we are going to
discuss now i encourage everybody look
at 29 right now
and 12 29 has some duties assigned in
there work with other state agencies is
identify potential legislation intended
to reduce student hunger among students
whose families meet the okay guidelines
um
to me this this bill right here would
that committee and it's going to be very
hard to sell any kind of committee
to the full house this year when we
can't get people in the legislature to
serve on committees right now or you to
we have a lot of commissions which are
just drying up because of that so
i'd be very careful
president porter
mr chair this is just a process
question
if we um interim studied both of them
could the same
could we make a committee
sure that that's always a possibility so
it seems like maybe if it's a policy we
think is a good idea that maybe if we
could make the same committee work on
both
that would solve the problem of having
rough tanner thank you
i just i i would just
plead i guess
that
small family farms again uh and sullivan
county
definitely has their share of small
family farms
that to itl this gives a different
it's a it's a different message that
that i just can't be a part of i want to
be a part of
saying we like this policy which
may get out to the public through the
the video but
to see it in paper as a you know killed
in committee kind of thing i would
rather us do an interim study i know
that the
you know
it may be difficult getting a study
committee i'll volunteer for it
to start out but i and and i think it's
a what you know an idea
that um we don't want to just let it
drop and certainly to put it in with the
other bill
might be a possibility but it seems like
that other bill has some very specific
ideas that that agriculture could be get
get lost somewhere so
um again i would plead that we go for an
interim study rather than an itl on this
oh i'm sorry
represent mullen
thank you
as someone who is a sponsor on both of
these bills 1657
and 1229
i certainly can appreciate
representative ladd the idea of
streamlining the process
however i think the scope of the bills
in and of themselves are large enough
that if you try to give this to one
committee i think the one committee is
going to be buried in the details
looking at 1657 i want to be completely
transparent with you there were people
that worked far harder on this bill than
i did
though i was quite invested in the
process farmland is not
my
wheelhouse
uh however
looking at the number of organizations
that contacted us in support of this
bill the number of farmers individual
people that contacted us in support of
this bill
and looking at the sincerity of the of
the uh
camaraderie of the people on the
committee
i would venture to say that the thing
that we
that makes legislators successful
is their ability to have relationships
with one another
and specifically because of the fact
that
we don't know what the complexion of
this committee will be after november of
next year
i would ask that you look at this as an
interim study i won't be supporting the
itl on this uh and i would hope for an
interim study
to really honestly honor the work that
has already been done on this very
wholesome topic
so thank you for hearing me
represent cordelia
thank you mr chairman um i don't think
anyone on the committee does not
support local farmers
my son is a farmer
not in new hampshire but is a farmer so
that's you know close to my heart as
well
but
the interim study versus itl is not
going to make any difference the
vehicle can be used to look at this
the bill
certainly is is not
not ready
has
many many problems in including the
financial
and location origination aspects
it can be worked on
independently it can be worked on with
the other bill it can be worked on and
brought back in legislation
in any event
so
i don't think an itl motion is saying
that we do not want to
continue to look at the
topic
it is saying this bill is right not
ready and
we can bring it back
thank you
i just
there are a couple things i just wanted
to address that have made me
uncomfortable throughout the caucus the
you know
throwing out bipartisan or we're not
supporting the farmers
i most definitely support our farmers
i'm most definitely a team player
regardless of what the bill is and i
hope that you all know that
what i wanted to point out in listening
to testimony this bill it only applies
to those schools who are in the federal
lunch program it does not apply to all
schools but we actually had people from
the doe
that had testified we were told that the
actual cost of the bill is seven hundred
and eighty thousand dollars forty
thousand for new information systems
five hundred and sixty thousand for the
program reimbursements and hundred
eighty thousand dollars for the new
employees at the doe to oversee
i know mckenzie had specifically told us
that this effective date july 1st 2022
was not a feasible timeline for roll out
and i feel as though we continue to hear
from the attorneys as well the attorney
excuse me
and employees of doe that they're really
having a hard time filling their slots
right now for open employment
opportunities and here we are we're
about to add two more i would agree that
this bill has a lot of merit i'm just
not sure that it's ready either
thank you
further discussion
representative mullen
i agree with about 50 of what you had to
say representative flitchfield um
yeah 50 is good uh
keeping in mind two things one we're not
looking for this bill to be enacted
we're talking about studying it we're
taking we're talking about going back
and looking at exactly what you're
talking about the costs whether or not
we would be better off putting together
a pilot program and making
recommendations so uh you know
agreeing to an interim study is not
going to bind this committee nor
the state of new hampshire to anything
other than
it is a formal nod to
the fact that this is a worthwhile thing
to study
so i i would just and it's also a
voluntary program so
no school would be
mandated into uh participating in this
so
if the local costs in
brentwood don't support participating in
the program but the local costs in
woodsville do
then um you know i think we can
we can acknowledge the fact that not
every school system would be involved in
this unless it was of their own volition
so
again no
nothing binding the state to anything
just asking to take a look at things
thank you
is there further discussion on this bill
not seeing anything
just a a
question of the chair
so in an interim study the outcome what
what is the outcome the possible two
outcomes of an interim study
well it's simply that to make a
recommendation whether there's
it should move forward or not move
forward in terms of legislation and
interim studies also
can
provide more information
to you know
make the particular bill more
sustainable and and and and to move it
forward in a positive manner um
i believe well i won't go into what i
believe but that's exactly what
whether it's up or down
move forward or not
that's what we would be doing and it's
not necessarily move moving forward with
the language and the bill it's it's
whether it's recommended for future
legislation or not recommended for
future legislation exactly
such as we received yesterday from the
commissioner of agriculture and
marketing
um he made one comment that uh he's not
sure that
um
there
the agricultural products in this state
are enough to sustain on a long
sustainable process the food necessary
for a particular school or school
district
so there's a lot of questions have to be
asked on this and i quite truthfully i
think it's beyond what this committee
if if we had to set up what are all the
priorities for this committee right now
in terms of statewide education
your bill is extremely important i'm
talking foundation budget
mathematics in our school
is very important our scores are down a
whole lot yeah it's the pandemic but
they have been kind of flat-lined
anyways how do we improve
there's areas that we have to really
start looking at
and
for me this is important
but
i it's like i kind of jumped on doe the
other day and say what are your
priorities
and and um
what are our priorities if i had to say
honestly what my priorities are right
now um
we want to feed our kids we want them to
have a healthy meal we want them to be
well but this one right here is not the
top priority is what i would lay out for
what i would like to see studies done
so is there further discussion
madam clerk yes
i just wanted to say that
i i just wanted to reiterate that we all
support this idea
but i just wanted to say i don't think
i don't think we're the ones who have
the information that needs to
to study this that's all and man i
really want people to study this so my
recommendation is
people really ought to study this and
come up with something good for next
year i just don't think we're it thank
you
clerk could you please call the roll yes
and the motion is
the motion is ito for house bill 1657
farm to school
rep cordelli
yes
rep litchfield is a yes
representative boehm
representative lakis
i guess yes
representative moffitt yes
representative hopson
yes
representative ford
yes representative sony yes
representative nelson
yes
representative luno no
representative waltz no
representative tanner for our family
farms no
representative ellison
representative mullen no
representative woodcock
representative porter
representative hall
no
okay so that vote is ten to eight
in favor of ito
okay uh represent luna will
do
interim study yes there'll be a minority
report on interim study coming from
so they're having a
yeah tanner would be recommending is in
okay
relative to school lunches and
establishing the meals for students fund
uh representative uh hobson do you have
a motion
yes i have a motion i'd like to move
[Music]
do you have any discussion
yes uh i just wanted to point out that
we heard from the doe
out of
new hampshire
schools participating in the nhslp
30 of these schools are not providing
breakfast
so to that end i believe that most of
the schools are already providing these
services
and to start up a new program
would uh the costs would be
indeterminable uh according to mackenzie
the start-up costs the the program to
continue oversight
they would place a fiscal burden on
taxpayers so for that reason i vote itl
thank you
motion ito thank you
uh is there any discussion from this
second
uh no what she said i i agree
thank you
open to comment on the committee here
yes represent ellison uh thank you mr
chair i'll be voting against the motion
uh
i think the the issues are real clear on
this
and it's a dilemma that we as a
committee face almost daily
and
the issue here is feeding kids or local
control of education
and i will come down always on the side
of feeding children
and i think this committee should too
the issue of an appropriation and how
much money it costs goes to finance
we're a policy committee finance decides
those things the issue of how many
schools are involved
maybe 30 it may be as many as 37 or 40.
so i will be voting against the motion
and i would encourage you all to do that
as well
we we are the richest country in the
world we are a bread basket for
everybody
i will be voting against this motion i
see no reason that any child in this
country should ever be hungry and i will
always vote to feed children i will also
say this is now the second or third bill
where i've heard a discussion from the
policy committee talking about the cost
of this and as somebody who sits on the
finance committee i would remind you
that that really is the purview of the
finance committee that we should be
looking at the policy is feeding kids
the right thing to do and let finance
figure out the money on this
but we should be feeding children no
child should ever be sitting anywhere
hungry so that's why i'll vote against
representative nelson thank you mr
chairman parent responsibility parents
should take the responsibility to make
sure that dear children are fed they had
it years ago
mom and dad fed us i think we're losing
that today and we expect government to
be doing it for us so i will vote
reps and like us
my issue as with so many other things is
i believe it's a 28a violation because
even though we're reimbursing for the
cost of the food
we're not reimbursing for the cost of
the preparation etc and these schools
may not have anybody hired at the time
that it would take at the time of day
that they would need to prepare lunches
and so we're asking them
for these startup costs and the costs of
the
workers etc
and we're not paying for that
and that's my problem with it once again
we're telling schools they have to do
something that's going to cost them
money and we're not providing the full
cost
of what it is we're telling them to do
and that's against our constitution
thank you
for reference thank you representative i
appreciate the opportunity to comment i
would just take take
issue with president nelson's comment
i agree that mom and dad when available
went home and wouldn't have the
financial resources to do that but the
school has been providing meals for
children for years
think of our most recent costly program
that we've taken out of the education
trust fund for moms and dads to keep the
kids home which is their responsibility
four thousand bucks a piece we're asking
to every youngster to get the most
important meal of the day is breakfast
and now we're saying we can't these are
folks who are already
on federal programs so they can't have
enough
money to support their children going to
school
in terms of feeding them properly the
best thing we can do for education make
our kids are there they're warm they're
healthy they're mentally together and
they're fed
thank you thank you
uh other
comments from the committee
representative luno
thank you mr chair and i think that i
think the discussion here has been
compelling
uh i'm not going to support the itl
motion and when you take a look
because some of the conversations been
about cost when you take a look at at
our all-in costs in public public
schools across the state local state and
federal dollars 3.2 billion dollars a
year and we're talking about
what six hundred and
fifty thousand dollars here to um as a
doe expenditure
i i and i don't buy the art the local
argument i mean yeah it's got in
indeterminable but we're not talking
about millions and millions and millions
of dollars here certainly not 3.2
billion dollars and the science is out
there that that um that
kids need to be fed in order to learn
and if we're making that type of
investment in our public schools i think
making a little bit of
an investment to make sure that our kids
start the day
so that they're ready for the first
class of the day um is money very well
spent so i i can't support the itl
representative porter
thank you mr chair
we have a lot of conversations in this
committee about closing the gap between
achievement gap between
districts that have high
numbers of free and reduced lunch kids
versus
those that don't
making sure that children have food so
their brains can work when they get to
school is a key element to closing that
gap
and i so for that reason i cannot
support itl in this bill
thank you
further discussion representative tanner
thank you um after teaching 35 years
it was very apparent to me
kids come to school and they're hungry
and as a teacher and probably anybody
that's taught in the public school
system or has taught
um had the same experience i did and
that was that i kept peanut butter
crackers
uh in my office for a kid that that
really was struggling
and at least it was a little bit of
nutrition
in my area there's
a couple of small groups that have even
formed
to
make sure that kids are fed
on school holidays teacher work days
the weekends
and um also during vacation week
we
have kids who are food insecure they go
home they don't there's nothing at home
okay and maybe that's the parent's fault
but the kids should not suffer
because of what is at home or not at
home
there's no as mary beth said there's no
reason
new hampshire is one of the more
wealthier states in the wealthiest
nation
and there's no reason
why
a student in new hampshire
shouldn't should be hungry should come
to school hungry
we also have a number of homeless kids
homeless families
uh
and these kids
you talk about food insecurity
or what they get you know maybe a french
a large french fries at mcdonald's
um you know is certainly different than
what we can give them at school and you
know we've been talking thanks to
representative horrigan and also to the
people that did the agriculture in the
classroom and in the in the uh
for meals um you know trying to to work
on nutrition trying to because not only
are they hungry but if they're
if they're getting foods that are not
nutritionally
well-rounded and and good for them
it also affects their learning um and
their ability to sit still
um in class so
i i just uh will not support
the motion on this bill further
discussion from the committee
not seeing any uh representative
litchfield would you please uh
identify the motion and the bill and
take the role yes um
the motion is itl this is bill number
1660 relative to school lunch and
establishing a meals fund
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
oh i'm sorry
i'm waiting for you just to answer
representative boehm
yes
representative lakes
representative moffett yes
representative hobson yes
representative ford
yes representative soti yes
representative nelson yes
representative luno no
representative waltz no
representative tanner no
representative ellison no
representative mullin no
representative woodcock no
representative porter no
representative hall no
chairman ladd yes
okay um the motion of ito
and there will be a minority report of
uh ought to pass and it will come from
the next bill to turn to which is also
an early bill is 1661.
uh we did have an amendment on that bill
and um
for those that don't have it i've got
yes yes yes there'll be extras going i'm
you
i think
everyone have should have a copy of the
amendment
um
okay
i will
call on uh
chairman ladd for
so what i'm going to do is make a motion
ought to pass on the bill
1661.
so
okay to uh
proceed
and
then in section three the old is the
only change
[Music]
do you want to introduce the amendment
um
seconds the motion of ought to pass and
i was just checking to make sure it all
yes
h
second anyone
representative boehm
uh
would representative
could you put your microphone on please
sir
so uh
cte agreement
is set up whereby
we have all districts which are sending
to the center
and the center agreeing to
a four four-year agreement how they're
going to function and operate in terms
of their scheduling
classes that are taught transportation
all that's in the rctea agreement
and what the amendment does it then adds
in that we're going to try to get all
these districts
into a
similar schedule or as close as we can
get the schedule
the original bill said five days that
were dissimilar days this has been
changed to include 10 dissimilar days as
requested by the directors
and
and by doing this
it goes from after labor day through the
last day so you're going to have a lot
of dissimilar days of course on the
front side of labor day
uh
seeing that different start times
however from labor day onwards there's
only 2 10 dissimilar days
many of the
regions are currently
looking that we have 28 different
centers and
centers in our system of which five are
out of state on the vermont side of the
river
and
it's a challenge to get all the
schedules on the same wavelength because
we have negotiated agreements and that's
why we have this four year period to try
to arrive at this dissimilar
get down to a december of only 10 days
this is important from the standpoint of
students attending the centers
if you're on different calendar days
like you have this day off a little
vacation you have this one right here
and they're not similar
then you have kids which are going to
the cte centers you have transportation
issues
which the child has to get themselves to
the school and then the school most
school districts are providing that
transportation to the center
on a day that the
ascending district's not in session for
one reason or another but the center may
be in session
we're also trying to get our our
schedule set up internally within the
schools so that we're talking about the
length of a course there's a real
difference of course between new
hampshire and the state of vermont where
we have five of our centers
where a cte
course which is part of a program
which has a cluster of courses within it
uh is two hours over there it's an hour
and a half here so when we ship kids
over there there's a different
arrival time you might arrive in the
middle or the end and the same thing's
occurring even internally within our own
state so we're trying to get that
internal schedules of the courses the
block scheduling and all that squared
away as well
the second part which you'll see on the
amendment which deals with and of course
there's waivers for this let me get back
to the waivers on the 10 day we know
there's going to be emergencies we know
there's going to be exceptions which are
are very
uh good exceptions that are needed
we're living in one right now with covet
and of course you have snow days and one
part of the district may have a snow day
here but there may be absolutely no snow
on the other side that's typical new
hampshire in places
so so there can be requests that the
commissioner approves for exceeding the
10 days which are based upon emergency
and exception but there's also
another exception which we built into
this with the the change in the
amendment
that if the district's sending and the
receiving
center
are working towards us actively working
to try to get their
calendars in line so they get into this
10-day non-alignment requirement or less
that they have through the ability to
through
july 1 2026
to get this other exception done if
they're all reasonably taking effort and
working cooperatively and they're moving
to that direction
there's no reason why they should be
harmed for doing what they should be
doing
now the fourth part of this
deals with
the
embeddedness of competencies
that into the courses at this rcte
center we know that there's
general requirements which we have based
upon education 306
that are required for you to graduate
from a school in new hampshire every
school has to offer 43 different courses
but there are certain required courses
that you must take
and you have an option with the elective
courses
we have in some situations in the state
where students which we now have in in
manchester a kid can attend grades 9
through 12 in a ct elsewhere in a state
it's grades 10
through 12.
we know that there are some students
that are unable to make the cte program
which might be five miles from where
their ascending school is due to the
fact that the one course they need for
graduation is being offered
when the cte course and programs being
offered
at the receiving center
that's
that's contributing to the issue that in
this state we only have 17 percent of
our kids participating in cte
that cte is necessary for prepare kids
for the united states kids students for
career and success in the past what they
might choose but if we're denying the
opportunity
to attend the center do the fact there's
a conflict
in scheduling when in fact
the competency which are taught in that
course back in the high school maybe its
chemistry
or mathematics
are embedded into the course at the cte
center or into the courses you get
partial credit the way this is written
on your partial competencies but
remember when you're in a particular
cluster whether it be a medical cluster
or or a restaurant or in diesel
mechanics or whatever or mathematics
there's a number of courses
and you could spread out these
competencies
for that chemistry maybe in several
different courses at the cte
now the approval process for approving
these competencies is not done through
the state or the state board or the
commissioner it's done by way of the
agreement if you look at the way it's
been reworded it's been reworded so it
has to have the approval of the sending
district
and working with the
career technical education center
and that is i think conforms to where
our discussion was when we uh discussed
this earlier
yeah and lastly
um you're on board
okay
uh so um and and the effective date of
this as you can see july 1 2023 which
was also a recommendation for change
representative uh as the
maker of the second
yes just uh just a quickie i was on the
committee that worked on this too and
yeah it was a big diff and everybody's
fighting it to align the calendar days
and i remember when i was on the school
board in litchfield we deliberately
aligned it with hudson they're not
playing those games anymore they're not
but the problem with some districts like
region 16 which is include hudson
litchfield nashua merrimack milford and
amherst
there are three cte centers in that one
region
and the problem is is aligning the days
and hopefully we can get it done i know
they were working to get it done but
yeah
definitely needs it
any further discussion on the amendment
representative woodcock thank you
chairman cordelia just a question of
representative ladd on the amendment
just so i understand
rick if a school is
in a cte and is in a single district i'm
talking particularly conway
do they have to also conform to this to
the other ctes where they're only
receiving students from the district
if you you're going to have students
coming in from uh another district two
are you talking about no we just have we
have in the high school we only have one
district yeah two districts but in high
school there's only one yeah so um
does rcte in the north over there in
north carolina have to align their
schedule
with the other ctes in the state under
this proposal no not with others in the
state but for students which coming from
sending schools to that if it's all in
the house
like concord okay so it's just one just
single okay okay okay thank you honestly
thank you i got it thank you appreciate
it
okay thank you appreciate it
representative porter thank you um rick
i just have a quick a question about the
partial credits
for competencies what
how does how would it work then if
okay there's five credits let's say make
it easy and the cte provide it covers
three of those but the other two it does
not cover
how does that work then the
local school is responsible for
putting that kid into some course that
will cover those two competencies
the the whole process has to be approved
and embedded in that rctea agreement
so the schools are going to have to
concur and work towards this end that
you're talking about
the there are some schools
are already doing this right i i just
wanted to know but it's up to the rcte
agreement that that particular school
district and the center
the sending agree upon and this is all
approved in there
okay so uh i don't i don't think there
should there'll be a lot yes there's
going to be a lot of hurdles to jump
because uh this is a tremendous step but
we need to go there we need to get like
delaware they have over 50 percent of
their high school students participating
at least one cte course we only have 17
percent in this state we can ill afford
to stay
like that we got to do something thank
you any further discussion uh questions
uh seeing none um
madam clerk could you call the role on
you can't do either way yeah or or
on on on an amendment you can do a voice
or you can raise a hand
and this is actually good to lay out now
because when we were when we were remote
we had to roll
right yeah that's right
but we're all here and you're on
amendment you can do that on the final
you can't right
yeah okay um in that case um
maybe we can have a show of hands anyone
uh supporting amendment three five six h
all right that looks to be everybody i
don't anyone that i missed
anyone that i missed
raise their hand i think we got
everybody in favor of the amendment
so that would be uh
did you want to make a motion on
amendments i'd like to move 1661 ought
to pass as amended with the amendment
zero three five six h
okay this is ought to pass with the
amendment and this is house bill 1661
career technical education agreements
rep cordelli
yes
rep litchfield is yes rep foam
rep legus yes brett moffatt yes
representative hobson
yes representative ford
yes rep sony yes
rep nelson yes
representative luno yes
representative waltz yes
representative cornell
oh not here just kidding what's up
tanner
yes
representative ellison yes
representative
yes
representative woodcock
representative porter yes
representative hall yes
and chairman ladd yes
okay so octopass with the amendment um
with everybody
i think so great dave do you want to do
your bill now or do you want to take
okay
okay the next bill that we're going to
move on thank you very much for you know
moving the career attack that's
near and dear to this person's heart
and i think to a
a lot of folks throughout this state i
appreciate it
um
well if we're going by
yeah
[Music]
okay yeah okay i just wanted to read it
establishing a foundation opportunity
budget program for funding public
education we've had a subcommittee
working on this we've only met three
times
uh
it's been very productive it's been very
interesting and um we're
nailing down a lot of those issues
associated with funding education in
this state
and providing all students that
opportunity which we want them all to
receive
so
i like to
move uh interim study
on on 1680
and
i i give the gavel to
just recognize me and then
i'll and i'll second that one you got
two
moved by uh representative vlad seconded
by representative luno
um
comment from the uh maker of the motion
yeah i'll do it very briefly uh
represent luna of course has been he
worked with this and i worked with this
on the commission during the last year
and a half
there's a lot to this bill and a lot
that we have to address you know
throughout this state
and this still this bill is touching
upon
a lot of aspects and delving into
certain elements
and areas that comprise this bill in
ways that we're doing it thoroughly and
we're trying to ensure that all students
in the state have that opportunity
and
i i don't want to get into things like
weighted formula but we know we have a
constitutional issue going on in our
state right now this bill is critical to
our working in that direction and so i'd
like to support absolutely support this
interim study we need to do a lot more
work and talking about not just talking
we are every time we get into this
we learn a little bit more maybe we
should get information here or there
i i think that's extremely exciting and
so i'm hopeful that we can come out of
the interim study and this would be
as far as i'm concerned a real genuine
hard-working interim study
so thank you
representative luno comment hey thanks
uh very much and i think representative
ladd's uh comments uh uh absolutely hit
it on the head i couldn't have said it
any better and i want to thank
all the members who worked on the the
interim study on this and as well as um
representatives from um from the
department of education department of
revenue administration and uh and other
groups that contributed to the work so
thank you
further discussion representative porter
thank you mr chairman and i was
fortunate enough to be part of the
subcommittee um i think it's real
important to have this
here for us because we do have several
court cases still waiting to be decided
and having such a framework
in on the back burner will be very
helpful depending on how those court
cases
come forward so interim study i think we
need to work on it and i think it's an
excellent
see none
madam clerk
okay this is bill number 1680
relative to establishing a foundation
opportunity budget program for funding
public education the motion is interim
study
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
yes representative lacus
yes
representative moffett yes
representative hobson yes representative
ford yes representative soti yes
representative nelson
representative luno yes representative
waltz yes
representative tanner yes representative
ellison
representative mullen
yes representative woodcock
representative porter
representative hall yes
and chairman ladd yes
okay in terms study 18 to 0.
thank you to all again um we got our
work cut out for us
we got our work cut out
okay
do you want to take a break right now uh
we're going on 12 15.
well one left on this this group of
bills it's that we got more bills than
okay
was there any desire to put the uh the
last bill on the consent
if we can yeah sure yes okay no but no
there's an amendment for this bill right
here
uh we're the last bill we're going to do
before lunch time here
is hp 1684 limiting education freedom
representative cordell you're recognized
for a motion
uh thank you mr chairman i would like to
move uh itl
on
i'd like to second thank you
so we have a motion on on the table for
itl in 1684 made by cordelli second by
lakers
um
the ito motion has been made
that means that if it passes we won't be
discussing
uh representative luna's
amendment is that accurate
that's the way it works thank you
unless uh
it's i i will allow that to be discussed
though
so
go ahead thank you
um
house bill 1684
establishes a budget
for the education freedom accounts
um education freedom accounts program
has been
[Music]
successful this year
over 1800
students
there is um
some
concern
um
about
the number of students
who are cons
i'm more concerned that there are 1800
students
having an opportunity to get the
education they need
you know we've heard quite a bit of
discussion this morning about
the need for breakfast and the need for
meals and how important that is i'm also
important
very
concerned about education
academic achievement
students being able to
meet all their opportunities and goals
and be the best they can be
in the best situation
to meet those needs in a public school
then
i think that they need the opportunity
implement a budget for this program
and
kick kids out of a program that might be
very successful for them
i think that would be
disastrous
for many children who
would experience
we need
as a state
as a country
to provide the education
that every child needs
public education is also about educating
the public
is there a discussion from the maker of
the second
mostly ditto
um i do wonder do we
[Music]
if we have students a whole bunch of
students move into the state from out of
state
do we say well we didn't budget that
many
for the amount that the state pays for
those kids and tell them they can't go
and i see that as sort of if we have
these kids
who decide they want to do this and we
haven't budgeted for them because we
didn't know they were going to be there
i don't think we should be telling them
further discussion represent luna thank
you very much mr chair so
we budget for a lot of things in the
state of new hampshire in fact we every
two years we
create a thing called the um the
biennial state budget
and includes a lot of things that are
really important to granite staters like
dcyf caseworkers are budgeted do we have
enough
are we meeting the needs of those
children what happens if we're not
meeting the needs of those children what
happens if we don't budget enough
we budget here in new hampshire we
budget the number of caseworkers we have
at dcyf taking care of
looking
out for
the interests of our of our kids we put
a budget on the um the developmentally
disabled waiting list
to try to keep that as small as possible
when we don't budget enough guess what
happens
it's not it
it's not unthinkable to budget things
here in the state and what that also
does is it holds our leaders accountable
to
making reasonable estimations when
putting forward a budget so what did we
see last year
when the efa program was budgeted
commissioner of education this this is
not even a year ago
budget 129 000
presented a 13-page
that um
yeah yeah that um that that
showed
28 students
being expected to enroll in the first
year and uh and actually i do have it
it's on the back of this 21 of those
transitioning directly from public
for from
from
students not in public schools and
and three from from home education
backgrounds going into the uh the efa
program
so what do we find out wasn't it wasn't
nearly what uh what was budgeted
75 percent of the students did not come
from public schools and um and end up
providing a you know a
realization in
lower costs at the at the local level in
fact only 17 percent of the students
came directly from public schools and 83
percent of the students came from
private and home schools and uh and had
actually come from private and many of
those came from private and home schools
um i'm sorry had already exited of those
students all of those students who come
from private and home schools had
already exited their public school
district so
when um uh what does that mean for the
state budget well the state budget
included 129 000 for the fa program the
actual cost for fy um
is closer to 8.1 million
most of those students already attending
private and home schools
and
where do we see this going well hard to
tell given what the uh given what the
commissioner budgeted because um
because um next year the uh the the
commissioner
uh budgets for only um 649 students and
we've already got
uh almost a thousand more um students in
again primarily that already came from
home school and private school
situations
my understanding is we're going to be
getting the actual numbers from from the
scholarship organization going to
provide a breakdown of
of how many students came from home
school
private school and public school when
matriculating into the efa program so
that we can know exactly what uh what
the savings to local taxpayers
uh has uh has been and which was a
leading
case made by
the commissioner when when when
supporting the education freedom account
program i guess in the end
the program is no more important or no
less important than so many other
programs that we budget for here in the
state and um and having a
having the commissioner come in make the
case for the budget
would uh would would be appropriate
rather than it being a um a blank check
and what the amendment does
is addresses i think concerns that were
were aired
during the uh during the public hearing
on 1684
uh that went along the lines of what are
you going to do with the students
already in so all the amendment does is
for fy 22
goes with the actual uh budgeted amount
for um uh for this year based on the the
commissioner's numbers and then for fy
23 um adds on another group of students
based on what the commissioner saw or
marks down as efa switchers from 2021
puts in the same number of students
multiplies multiplied by the the average
efa
so that we're not holding anything back
for 22 and 23 and then by the time we
get around to the next biennial budget
cycle i think the commission will have a
little bit better uh history with with
how to budget this budgeted accurately
and be held accountable to it thank you
thank you
further discussion representative
woodcock
thank you chairman i appreciate the
opportunity um i just want to bring a
couple things out the the
17 percent of the youngsters that
withdrew from public school
to participate in the efa program
uh numerically that's if i had my math
right or through the computer uh that's
272 out of the 1600 or more kids i
understand representative
cordelli talking about the public edu
public education and the public needs to
be educated
the public needs to be educated that 83
of these kids weren't there the public
needs to be educated that this tax money
that we're talking about is going to
private schools catholic schools
religious schools not public schools or
home schools that's that's part of the
information that the public needs to
know about their public tax dollars
thank you
griffin lakers
i was just going to ask a question but i
will say that i have talked to numerous
of those parents who say
why isn't my kid as important as
everybody else's kid and how come you're
not willing to pay that little bit that
little bit compared to the twenty
thousand
that four thousand for my kid to at
least be able to get on school education
but my question was um
the number
[Music]
for those anticipated to come in next
year do you know when that was made is
that recent or is that a while ago so
that number was uh was uh basic was from
the efa fact sheet
which was um provided by the department
to the
efa over is an oversight committee
uh back in november of uh the end of
last year
so and my my understanding is that these
are this is actual data from from this
year so
further represent tanner
uh thank you
um i want to say that that for me i've
been
really concerned about the
accountability both financially and
academically of the of the program the
faa program but i'm also i'm
particularly concerned because of my
fiduciary responsibility to the
taxpayers of new hampshire
to allocate funds
that are public funds that are
reasonably budgeted and accounted for
and
you know i serve on the
school budget committee and i serve on
the town budget committee the town i'm
from
and in both those areas i've never seen
an open checkbook i've never seen
um a program that's or
a department that's come in
uh either in the public school system
the town itself
that uh that the people from for example
transportation come in and say
okay uh we need to fix all the roads in
in sunapee um i don't know exactly how
much that's going to cost but we really
need to so
please give me an open checkbook
and basically i think that's what we've
given with this program
i remember when
193 came out with the
first program of the education
scholarship fund and i remember
a very distinguished representative
from where
who had
tremendous angst about the fact that
there was not a cap on that program
and
i just think that
it makes sense to get the information
out to the public
through this budgeting
what this program is actually costing
for the 17 or
of the of the
participants uh versus the 160 000 kids
that are still in public school
uh that every penny in a public school
system
is accounted for and so that's my my
major concern
thank you
further discussion representative nelson
basically a question i'm curious as to
what the cost is if somebody moves into
town or city and what would the cost be
for that child to walk into the
classroom based on the budgets i think
it's like twenty thousand of my way
fifteen thousand
versus them going through this program
would it cost more or would it cost less
to that town to educate one additional
student
so uh you know i can i can respond to
that by having spent 12 years on a
school board but the marginal cost the
incremental marginal cost of one student
is not the same thing as the school
budget divided by the adm or the
enrollment of the student
it's it's not that way in education it's
not that way in business it's not that
way for a lot of things
um what you uh what what um what schools
find and what uh what com what
businesses find is that is that there
tends to be a marginal cost when you
either
do one more thing
have one more student come in it's not
the average cost of what it costs to
let's say educate a thousand students
educating a thousand and one students
doesn't increase that budget
by the average cost per student it's a
marginal cost per student so i would i
would
i this is something that's actually
worth
a i think a significant um economic
study to better understand but i think
an argument could be made that
the uh that the marginal cost
uh for a uh for for one additional
public school student in the manchester
school district may in fact be less than
the um the the what the what the efa
program
um uh
does in its um
for its state allocation
so but but that would be worthy i think
of additional economic study
yes
i often see you know we have a student
the school board will say
we've increased our number of students
so it's going to cost us another x
amount
you know when kids come in now we have
over the number that are allowed in the
classroom 15 so now we have to have an
extra teacher
that's big expense that's adding it on i
know where you're coming from and i
agree but that's a big expense all of a
sudden your budget ends up going 60 000
so i just think where i understand where
you're coming from but i think it's a
budget game
15 15 students
times uh you know you
15 students leading to a 60 000 increase
cost would be would be a 4 000 marginal
cost of per student not a 20 000
marginal cost per student
representative porter you've had your
hand up yeah a couple of things mr chair
so
for about 12 or 14 years my husband and
i ran a private preschool and
kindergarten
program in town
and
[Music]
we had certain fixed expenses we had
insurance we had
you know the the heat and electricity
and and phone service for the classroom
we had
supplies to buy we had all sorts of
expenses that you would have in doing
that
and we were limited by the number of
kids we could have by the size of our of
our classroom
when we
lost a student we would get you know
we'd have 10 kids enrolled
we'd get a certain amount of income in
if a student left
that did not reduce any of those costs
to us at all
the only thing it reduced was the amount
of income coming in
so where that cost was absorbed was in
the sal you know
that's what happens when a kid moves out
of the public school
it doesn't change
how much it costs to run the buses for
the other
950 kids it doesn't change the amount of
salaries or benefits for classroom
teachers it doesn't change um the amount
of fuel
it takes to heat the building it doesn't
change the maintenance costs the
cleaning costs and all the other myriad
of things that goes into running a
school
when we make the average
cost per student
and it comes out to be twenty thousand
dollars
taking a child away is not going to
reduce those costs by twenty thousand
dollars
and i think that's something that we
need to understand when we're talking
about this and that the public needs to
understand
and the second issue that i i would like
to address is something that um
representative alec has mentioned about
numbers of students moving into the
state to take advantage of the program
and i'm wondering
is the goal of this program to move many
children from out of state
into the state so they can receive these
public dollars from the public schools
to be home schooled is that what we are
trying to do with this program
or as the goal of this program i thought
was to give low-income children a chance
to attend a different
educational setting if they needed to
so i'm just throwing those two things
out there for your consideration thank
you thank you representative cordelli
uh thank you mr chairman um if i could
in the past with all other states
the projections for number of students
enrolling in efa
are a little bit different because now
we are in a situation where we
have a pandemic
so those numbers um really are apples
and oranges as it turns out
and with the numbers provided by the
department in november
the
switcher number really if you look at
the switchers including covid
is 43 percent switchers
point one uh two
um it seems
in terms of the arguments about
dollars and so forth
it seems that when
enrollment increases
all costs are variable
but when enrollment decreases all costs
are fixed
i'm just curious about that and thirdly
discussions about this we've heard
that
government funds are being sent to
religious schools and private schools
and so forth
it's not the case
government funds
public funds are given to families
families then
make the choice of how those education
the court has ruled that way going back
to
pierce versus society of sisters in 1924
zellman v simmons harris in 2022 and
espinoza versus montana
and quoting um
uh the court in zellman versus harris
the establishment clause permits neutral
government programs
where individuals individuals recipients
of that money
direct public aid to religious
institutions or other institutions
to
exclude religious institutions would be
discriminatory and you would have
a host of lawyers in here
the next day filing a lawsuit against
can against new hampshire if we ever
tried to do that we were told that um in
a meeting um
several years ago when we first
well
second or third time we tried to pass an
efa program
but
um
to to limit the uh budget and let's talk
about the education trust fund
is not a budget it's it's an education
trust fund in statute now if the trust
fund needs money
the governor takes a warrant to move
monies from the general fund into the
education trust fund because it is a
priority to educate children
the same thing would happen as this
we cannot
limit
a program like this
when it comes to education um it's
unfair to the the children
and just in terms of homeschoolers
homeschoolers save this
state
take the number of homeschoolers and
multiply that by
to say that
homeschoolers should not be involved in
this
you're saving a lot of money when
children
or families decide to home school
so
again it's it's wrong to bring up
homeschoolers as as possibly a draw or a
negative when it comes to participation
in this program
um i think that's all i have for the
moment anyway thank you very much
representative
a few things one my comment was not
saying we should pull people in from
other states to do this my comment was
saying that
if we had unexpected children coming
from out of state to our public schools
we would not say no you can't come
because we didn't budget for you and so
i was saying we should not do the same
thing for other students
who are in this state who decide to
enroll in this and because we didn't
expect them we should not be saying no
you can't come this
people talk about this a lot and they
try to compare it to
medicaid or other things that happen in
the state that we don't provide for
everybody and they say well it's not
like other programs and my point is
you're right it's not like other
programs when it comes to health and
that kind of stuff we don't provide
health insurance for every person we
provide an education that is what we're
supposed to do provide an education for
every student
and this is what we're trying to do
provide an education for every student
and if you happen to
if public school works out for you and
you put your kids in public school and
it works that's wonderful the state
provides money
if it doesn't work out for you why
should you have to pay it all out of
your own pocket which you don't
necessarily have
why can't the state provide that same
money that they provide if public school
works if public school doesn't work
and
and i think the other thing is
obviously it doesn't obviously there are
marginal costs and they don't save that
much money i want to know you said well
for manchester it would be little well
you picked the largest school district
we have what about the small school
districts when you have one come or one
go how much does that cost and i would
like to know i agree with you i would
love to know
what the marginal cost actually is
because it's not like where she had a
limited number of kids she could take
and therefore
you know she had very fixed costs that
were going to be the same that's not
like that in a public school
you have
you have kids not coming just because of
demographics you know our numbers are
shrinking just because of demographics
and one kid plus or minus in the small
schools can make a huge difference
and and you know whether or not you have
to have another teacher whether or not
you have to run another bus whatever
and so
i would like to know i agree with you i
would love to know how much the marginal
cost for each school district is
thank you
representative woodcock
thank you this is one show all right
okay um yeah we're on it i'll keep it
short thank you uh i would just
i think the
going back to representative nelson's
initial question about how much is one
person cost
uh
the
heat as president reporter said the
yellow school bus is going to show up
without regardless of what you take out
of there one more student coming in
during the middle year is not going to
change the budget because the budget's
already set that's not going to change
but representative quarterly does make a
good point it's interesting how we do
see enrollment go down school budgets
but sometimes school budgets don't go
down when aroma goes down and that's
that's a whole different piece by itself
but but the
the idea of and i understand the supreme
court rulings
but it to me it's just semantics
representative mullin gives me money for
his tax money and i get it
and i give it to a private school no
different it's just a and i hate to use
the word laundry because not but it's
just it's just semantics our tax dollar
is going right through me to
representative ellison if he was the
private school and that's that's where
it is it's going to private religious
school it's just semantics how it gets
there has one more stop uh i think
that's that's the feast and i do agree
the the home school is would cost you
as representative cordelia said a
significant amount of dollars in the
budget if they had been enrolled but
they weren't
so this is just giving them money
reps and hobson ralph i just have one
so
uh i just want to
clarify something so
if if a cost per student is 20 000
we estimate that the education freedom
amount is approximately 4 500 if they
want to use it they have to apply for it
it has to be approved expenses through
approved resources correct so there is
we'll say
14 000
from the local property tax that the
district still gets
with no student
to educate do i have that correct
so i'm assuming that question might have
been directed to me that's only if this
that's only if the student exits
their public school district if they are
already out of the public school
district all it is is an additional
and so the the facts that that we've
been presented by the department is that
83 percent of the students did not exit
their their public school
directly to uh to to enter the efa
program they were already either in
private schools or home school settings
uh having
you know not not
not costing the state um uh any expense
uh at all so that's that you know that's
uh no representative litchfield's had
her end up here she's waving it and then
representing like us but i want to
remind everybody that
you know we're gonna have a lot of bills
like this
and um
if we want to keep going i'm i'm all for
going but we're going to be whittling
but i think we're coming up to a bunch
okay great let's uh
represent litchfield yeah yeah you know
what i so i had an entire page of
comments here's what i'm going to do
first i'm now down to two representative
luna um i understand where you're coming
from and but i i also want to say like
bonus points for giving us a um
amendment with the three whole page
punch
really appreciated
yeah almost swayed me all the way yeah
um and then secondly um i think if i'm
going to take one thing out of this is
very important for me to convey is the
fact that the messaging needs to be out
there to the public that we are not
taking money away from the public
schools if the student is not attending
the public school right
whether it's private or wherever the
money is not going to go to that public
school anyway so there's just this
misconception and i hear it all the time
and i see it posted all the time on my
own social media where people are saying
you're you're taking away from the no
we're not we are not taking it from the
public school
perhaps
did you have
i just had two things one is when we
looked back like i had asked when the
bill was introduced when we looked back
at how many kids had left because of
covid and taking that into consideration
that it's 43 percent of the kids left
public schools
to go to this some of them just withdrew
just you know the year prior because of
coven and because their schools weren't
open and it's not it and
and and so you you need to count those
into those who transferred because they
left during covid when their school
wasn't open
and
so i think that's part of if there
hadn't been covered i think all of these
numbers would be different
but but according to the doe it's 43
percent
left
to go to this from public schools some
of them just did it
slightly earlier because they needed an
education for their kids and their
school wasn't meeting
but the other thing is the difference
it's not just semantics the difference
in the part and it's very
constitutionally important
is that there's a choice and who makes
the choice if the state makes the choice
to give money to the private school
then especially if it's a religious
school then that's a state choosing
to to send money or
to a particular or supporting a
particular religion whereas if it's the
parent who chooses
then it is not the state choosing and
the state is not instituting or
supporting a particular religion which
is the religious which is the
constitutional issue
if you read it doesn't say separation of
church and skate it doesn't say that
anywhere
i just have to breathe it's jus it's a
matter of the state supporting a
particular or
uh religious organization and if the
state is just giving the money to the
parent it is the parent supporting not
the state supporting and that's why the
cons that's why
the supreme court keeps saying that no
it is not the state's money and yes it
can go there
etc and i just wanted to point out
that's the difference between the state
just giving the money to the private
school or the parent giving it it's a
matter of choice and who chooses thank
okay folks uh
you know
we gotta make a decision whether you
know
you know it's i think we're moving on to
the point where the gorge is still there
and there's two sides of the gorge
so uh
represent waltz
this kind of millions of dollars of
unbudgeted money is still downshifting
to taxpayers and i'm not going to vote
for something that is downshifting to
the taxpayers to put money in private
pockets
and represent foreign the last hand i'm
going to recognize yes i'm i'm going to
urge the members of the committee
to go to
the libertarian institute
podcast
and listen to episode
that happened on november 6th
2021 i just urge you to listen to it and
then come back and
give me your impressions thank
you okay uh madam clerk we have a motion
on the table right now uh for 1684.
the motion is itl
you're really stealing my thunder here
excuse me will you go for it bill title
limiting education freedom account
funding to budgeted amounts
um okay representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
representative lakis yes of sam moffatt
yes
representative um hobson yes
representative ford yes representative
yes representative nelson
representative luno no
representative waltz no
representative cornell
i'm not here i keep doing that uh
representative tanner uh
no
representative allison oh
representative mullen no
representative
representative porter
representative hall no
excuse me
just a reminder
sure there's going to be a minority
report
okay and for those that are doing
reports uh try to be thinking about what
you're going to put in your report and
have it ready before we leave today
please
okay let's break for lunch that's a
great idea um
uh
back at one
who said that
okay so how much time do you need for
lunch
about a half hour
we never got an amendment their emotion
would be off the path yeah their
promotion will be ought to pass
otherwise they'd have to do a floor
amendment yeah that's right exactly yeah
yeah
are you passing yourself now no
no no no no no no no no
could you just double check my bills
that i'm
telling lindsay
11 30 yeah those those are for the 25th
starting at nine o'clock right yeah
those are hearings
so so we're gonna have to set times
um i just said you start at nine yeah oh
i see but you gotta get so that'd be
like nine
and then eleven thirty
let's see uh nine to ten
what's what is eleven thirty one
bill we had it's been heard
so it's more technical advice for us
right now
saying i don't think we have a lot of
engineers in this field here with us
today
could you just look at some of the
amending language which uh you know as a
result of what the commissioner
commissioner scott put in the letter
that we received that's in there
and
sure so um
the first the first item is kind of a
change in the timing of the sampling
that's required
so since the bill
since the original statute was put in
place
des has received funding from u.s epa
that would cover two rounds of testing
for public schools and licensed child
care facilities that's federal funding
you know the facilities were on their
own to complete the first round of
testing and most facilities have
completed the first round of testing
so the the change here would just be the
ch to change the timing of the sampling
rounds from every five years to
completing three rounds by june 2024 and
that's when the federal funding that we
have to pay for the testing runs out and
so that that was just the the change
there to be able to provide the support
um and we can cover the the lab costs
for all public schools and licensed
child care facilities
so that's the first the first change
um and then the next one is to
a requirement that all the sample
results be submitted to des
we have a
database where we've been tracking
data and um
we and and the original statute there
was no requirement to submit the data to
us and as we're going through and kind
of looking back at facilities that
didn't report data to us we're finding
some that did the testing but they
didn't provide us the data so this would
just have that requirement in there that
the data would be provided to des and
then we can track it better uh you know
people are interested in knowing how
many schools have sampled and what the
levels are and if we have a complete
data set then we'll be able to better
understand you know what um what the
situation is
and
then i think that next change was in the
was in the with the notification i think
that was in the original show
correct
uh and then the the change starting on
line 19 is related to post remediation
so if there's a fixture or drinking
water fountain faucet that tests high
they would need to do some sort of
remediation either change out the faucet
or put in potentially put in filtration
but
most of the time we recommend changing
out the faucet and then after you do
that testing it's important to take
another test
to confirm that what you actually did
remove the lead so if you change a
faucet you want to retest it to make
sure that that was actually the problem
and the problem wasn't actually coming
from somewhere else in the system and
so the current statute doesn't have a
requirement to do a retest
in the case of remediation and so that's
and the last one is the 485
correct the last one is the
enforcement and penalties and in the
original bill
uh the rsa referenced a different rsa
and so we recommended changing to this
rsa which is the appropriate one that
would um that you know that we typically
use for these types of violations
great that that takes through the
changes there you notice there's a
spelling mistake there on like 19 but
that's a technical thing that's taken
care of
uh when it goes to review it's not
we don't want to go through mediation
here
yes represent boom
thank you thank you question my question
is
what happens after june 30th 2024 we
on line
five
so i think at that you know at that time
if they if they had done all done the
testing and the results were all less
than the standard then they wouldn't
they wouldn't need to do any more
testing
okay represent luno
thank you very much mr chair and thanks
very much um ms
for
providing us with some technical support
on this um
sort of following up on what
representative foam
had asked i guess
how would
applying for receiving federal funds
is complete on
june 30th 2024.
so the funding that we have is through
the epa water improvement water
infrastructure improvements for the
nation act
and we were originally told that this
was kind of the last pot of money that
was coming through that grant program we
just received an allotment for this
current federal fiscal year
but with the bipartisan infrastructure
law that was um recently passed they uh
had said that there would be additional
money coming through that wind
that win program but we don't know
the timing of that or what that look
what
would the
would the department be
in a position then to
to
apply for whatever grants may become
available or
do
does that need to be in legislation
um i think it would be the intention
that we would apply for additional funds
are there can the department be of any
further help to us
on this
yes represent nelson thank you mr
chairman
is each faucet or water fountain need to
be tested
yeah so each faucet that's available for
consumption needs to be tested
so if you have you know a sink in a
janitor's closet that wouldn't need to
be tested
because hopefully no one's drinking out
of that that sink um
so but anything that is reasonably
available for consumption and so that
would include
that would include faucets and kitchens
that are used in food prep and cooking
drinking fountains
classroom sinks
things like that
yes i'm assuming that's somewhere
written down i'm sorry i don't
just miss it or it's another legislation
yeah so one line seven
lines six and seven that you have to
test at all locations that are available
for consumption by children i'm sorry
that's right thank you thank you
uh further further questions now
well leah thank you very much for coming
over
thank you and i guess just if you if i
could just um there is a bill in the
senate i'm not sure senate bill 452 if
that's something that that you're aware
of or looking at that has some of these
same changes but it also
would change the standard
for um for lead and drinking water at
schools and child care facilities yes we
are aware of what's going on in the
senate and perhaps you know
what when we this gives us two shots at
the apple sort of
yep okay
thank you thank you
um not seeing any more questions then um
well thank you very much leah and we're
going to
have a motion here
for
house bill 1421 um call on chairman ladd
for a motion i i thank you very much i'd
like to move hb 1421
a relative lead in school drinking water
as ought to pass
representative
discussion i think we just had it from
the department yeah
um
and
h
uh
uh two uh hb 1421
as ought to pass
okay
uh lad and luno
with the motions
not
not seeing anyone
oh do a hand vote sure
okay uh all those uh in favor of
looks to be unanimous
um
yeah i'd like to move the now hb
latin luna with the motions
any further discussion
thank you
so this is a vote on
house bill um
1421 as amended with amendment 0612h
relative to lead in school drinking
water
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is a yes
representative boehm yes
representative lacus
yes
representative moffitt yes
representative hobson
yes
representative ford
representative soti yes
representative nelson
representative bluno yes
representative waltz yes
representative tanner yes
representative ellison
represent mullen yes
representative woodcock
representative hall
yes and representative porter
uh chairman ladd yes
would be okay with everybody okay
okay thank you very much that uh is
going to roll on to the house right now
on the consent calendar um
and we will move on to the
uh bill that's 1074 charter school
special education meeting it's not the
relative to notice to a charter public
school of special education services
meeting
i just put them off i hope it goes
you want to
as that's coming around
do i hear a motion on house bill 1074
representative
yes uh representative i'd like to move
uh hb 10
7 4 ought to pass
second by representative hopson
any discussion representative land yes
i'd like to offer amendment
representative luno
discussion okay uh what what this does
to the original bill
you notice on lines
five on line five of this
it says shall invite a representative of
the charter public school to the meeting
the change down below on line eight for
all subsequent meetings of the iep team
the child's resident district shall
provide prior notice too
now this is where it changes from the
way it was
prior notice to the charter public
school
now it says to the representative of the
charter public school in conformance and
alignment with what's on
line five so you don't notice to a
school you notice to a person
and so this be rep to the representative
that's uh
of the chartered public school
any further discussion
so um sure and not to
belabor a point where where it's a
distinction without a difference but um
but i i
but
is is this amendment and actually the
maybe the bill
to um potentially
clarify
something that might be looked at as
being ambiguous in law whether the law
only applied to the first meeting or all
meetings i read it as the law would
apply to all meetings while a child is
enrolled by a parent in the chartered
public schools i read it the same way
yeah dave but uh evidently it hasn't
been followed that way
uh that we know of in all everywhere and
uh
so just to clarify it's a clarifying
that every iep
and the members of the ieb team are
notified by doing this the
representative that's identified here
will be notified whereas before it would
be the building and that's not a member
of the iep team that's the difference
but the the building was actually part
of the bill not part of the law
yeah
yeah yeah right right right right so
it's more clarification that notice goes
out to
that person yes
and um it's clarifying and i don't think
it hurts i actually i think it may you
know
improve upon so there won't be any
interpretation that's that's
further discussion
um
in that case um we'll take a
hand vote on the amendment all those
supporting the amendment please raise
looks to be
unanimous for the amendment 18
to zero
um
would the
chairman have a further motion yes uh
thank you mr chair i'd like to
move
otp as amended using zero five seven six
h
and second
represent
represented
would there be any further discussion on
the ought to pass as amended
seeing none i'm madam clerk
to you thank you
so vote on house bill number 1074
amendment zero five seven six h
relative to notice to a chartered public
school of a special education services
meeting
the motion is ought to pass as amended
representative cordelli
yes representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes
representative
yes representative moffett yes
representative hopson yes representative
ford yes representative soti yes
representative nelson
representative luno yes representative
waltz yes
representative tanner yes representative
ellison
representative mullen yes representative
woodcock
representative porter
representative hall yes and chairman
ladd yes
so this
is 18 to 0 ought to pass is amended
thank you consent everybody okay
great thank you
okay the next bill on the docket is 11
this bill
relative to applications for a charter
yes um
you want to do this
uh house bill 1132 yes mr chair i'll
move out to pass on 11
32. thank you and do i have a second
mr chairman i think we've had our
discussion hearing but i'll mention
again that
a charter conversion school is another
way of
developing a charter school within this
state
at this point in time i don't believe
there are any charter conversion schools
the process for doing that
is by vote of the school board and then
to become a charter school there are
other conditions which are required
one is you have a majority
of its prospective prospective teachers
and the teachers that are in the single
district right now and that's two-thirds
vote
and the other is you have to have the
approval of the superintendent and the
principal in writing
um this uh eliminates those latter two
categories that i just uh indicated and
and which i believe that there's
rationale for doing that sometimes these
teachers don't even live within the uh
the district itself
and it puts the um the option for going
that route and a part of the school
board and a majority vote of the
folks that are in that school district
at a rigor meeting or a special meeting
thank you
thank you representative hopson anything
further
any other discussion i see
representative porter's hand
thank you mr chair
i will be voting against the ought to
pass on this for the reason that
anybody can call a special meeting
it only takes 50 people to call one at a
town or a school district
attendance
meeting and i believe that having it be
a simple majority
of those present
to make such a major decision as this is
inappropriate
i believe that if you want to go this
route you should have it at least be a
three-fifths or a two-third vote
of the membership of the voters at that
meeting to because it's a major change
for a district
and it should not be a simple majority
you could have a meeting
with 50 people there
and 26 of them vote for this
and and end up changing your whole
school district
at the will of 26 people and i think
that's a dangerous slippery slope to go
down so i would highly recommend we vote
against this bill or
amend it to address that issue thank you
thank you further
discussion uh representative woodcock
thank you chairman cordelli a couple of
points
uh when the bill or the charter school
bill came in the conversion role
initially came in
it involved teachers and administrators
from the schools that are going to be
impacted
because that was their school
and now they're taken out of the mix all
together
in terms of
their potential
i see this more so though when
representative was talking about this
and
he talked about his outsourcing type of
piece and i think the terms he uses
saves money
at that discussion i asked about
examples and he indicated that well like
a library service for instance
uh you could close down the library and
use the public library then we talked
about the physical education pieces so
it's really um
in some respects i see this as an
opportunity to
break or eliminate the teaching union
the aft the nea if they're there because
we start to go through this charter
school we've taken out teachers we've
taken our supervisors we've taken our
principles we've taken out all educators
and now we're going to say okay we're
going to start outsourcing to save money
so i i find this i find this bill the
charter school provision for conversion
initially made sense in terms of if you
had a school within a school they wanted
within a district they wanted to go that
way thematically i get that i supported
that then but not now when i see the
union breaking money saving had nothing
to do to improve education from my
perspective
thank you
uh representative ellison uh thank you
mr chair i i guess this is a question to
rick i and i raised this during the the
hearing
and it gets to one of the issues that
we've just heard about which is the
labor agreements if there's a three-year
contract in place between a school
district and the teachers union
and this process takes place at the end
of year one and it goes to a
china public school
what happens to the
agreement between the teachers and the
school district for the next two years
after we have a have a
the conversion has taken place and i i i
asked that question then i don't know
that i have an answer to it i just would
be interested in uh
your opinion on that
well i don't think that just because you
have a charter conversion school means
you're going to have to rid yourself of
all the teachers within the building i
don't agree with that
and i also don't agree that that the
those teachers in that building can't
maintain their status as members of
either nea or aft i don't have any
problem with that either
so
[Music]
as far as the agreements that are in
place
that those are issues which would have
to be addressed between those designing
that new charter and there was a whole
process it's just one small part of the
whole process for this occurring you'd
have to look up in that part of the in
uh follow up
just following that then
it is possible then that
a labor agreement in the discussion that
took place going forward could be
negated
i would i i would say yes it could be
negated or it could be continued
okay thank you representative
thank you very much mr chair and so um
first of all i want to um sort of point
out that i i probably made an amateur
mistake on this
i think this is the only bill that uh
that at least on the line up here where
we're in disagreement where where you
are recommending ought to pass and we're
recommending um itl
and i think um we may have missed an
opportunity to prepare an amendment
that might may have been able to address
some of these
some of these concerns so i'd like to
put out three concerns that i think the
three
technical mechanical concerns that could
be should be
could be concerns for everybody
in this room but also granite staters um
in
in every uh in every town
and uh the first one i think marjorie
porter brought up which is um which is
could a could a conversion school
somehow be forced into creation through
a
through a a very much minority minority
minority um uh called special meeting
with with 50 names where where
um 50 people show up you know and
and
essentially put the town or put the
school district into a position where it
needs to um
to um um
you know to move forward with a uh with
a with a charter conversion school
um without the support of the of the
school board the
second concern would be
how does this um read with respect to
official ballot law so sb2 law where
deliberative session um might be able to
um to modify the warrant and put an
article on here i just don't know the
answers and and uh
on it and then the third i think is one
that um
that patty cornell has um has brought up
which is how will this apply to cities
that don't have um uh annual school
district meetings
and and i think all are reasonable um
um questions
uh i would certainly appeal to the chair
um if um if maybe we could uh be given a
little this is not an early bill right
no we're beyond that so to have time to
um to maybe look into those and to to
prepare
um
an amendment that um if if um
if it's found that that yeah there's
some holes in here that would be able to
prepare an amendment i mean i think it
is the
i i mean i i i'm certainly i think we
all feel that the work we do in the
house tends to be very detail oriented
maybe sometimes more often than what you
find on the other side of the
the um you know the wall so to speak
and
be um well this is what
we can see that privately well sure
chair hunt used to say it pretty
publicly i've done it on i've done it on
the floor of the house
um so uh but um
but
you know just uh just to make sure that
that we're not stepping into something
that that has a lot of unintended
consequences that's that's all i'm
putting out
if i could just um mention about special
meetings um
we had a number of towns um
the end of last year um have petitioned
drives to establish special meetings
um primarily in regard to mass mandates
and
i believe in all those instances where a
special meeting was held
there was a ruling that
the vote was not binding or in some
cases um
even though there was a petition
as called for in the statutes the school
board
elected not to
have that special meeting
so i think the process for a special
meeting is an open question um
there was
some
movement about
a lawsuit to challenge those rulings to
clarify
the statute about special meetings so i
would see special meetings as something
um that is an open question and should
not prevent us
moving forward
on that point
you know
fair enough on on that glenn but you
know in the case where we're
we're any meeting um even an annual
meeting i'm not sure
um that uh that a uh that an article
um with respect to masks
uh would even be binding at a at an
annual meeting um not much not less
certainly um
not a not a special meeting but in this
case
it's it's clearly opening the door
that that this is a an item
that can that could be considered at
either an annual meeting or a special
meeting
unlike a lot of you know like you can't
you can't force the school district to
run a lacrosse program if the school
board doesn't want to do that even if
you vote on it
um
at a annual meeting so those those are
non-binding
things so this this i think would be
binding because it opens
the door that it should be considered at
a meeting
uh president boehm
thank you mr chairman just to clarify
things that the school board's got to
propose it first before we have a
special meeting and also for
special meetings if people are notified
then they don't come it's their
fault
anyway also
i can see this happening in large towns
like hudson and derry and whatnot if the
school population goes down they might
be able to take one of their schools
rather than closing it
make it a charter conversion school so i
think i think this is a good idea as a
starting point thank you
representative uh
lakers yes i think it's a great idea and
i think having just the teachers instead
of the town vote on it is sort of
conflict of interest i think it really
should be the town but i'm a little
hesitant to make it
just a simple majority i kind of like
the three-fifths idea myself
and i think
various other of us sitting over here at
the table kind of like the three-fifths
idea
could we this isn't an early bill right
so could we put an amendment to change
it to instead a majority change it to
three-fifths
or district or however that would work
it would have to be the school voters
present at the meeting
right of the voters present but instead
of a simple majority be a three-fifths i
think it is a big thing
and i do agree with rep porter that it
should be a little bigger number and so
do
various of us over here think it's for
such a big thing
any other big things we have have to be
passed by that much as well so
well typically at meetings it's
two-thirds
on on sb2 it's three-fifths
right so we may have to put in wording
that says two-thirds at a school at a
meeting and
fifths at a election however
you know depending we will have you know
right right and i think i think um
um alicia what you're what you're
getting at here really my sort of
technical concerns with with this um
that that maybe
having a little more time to to get uh
get a full understanding of of how does
this read with sb2
how does this read with cities that
don't have annual or special meetings
um
how does this read with the special
meeting law uh and then maybe a
three-fifths or two-thirds depending
upon what your um what you've adopted
for uh official ballot
because it should be the same as going
to full-time kindergarten right the same
one yeah fraction president boehm yeah i
think that also since this is a big
thing for the town i think it would just
be at the regular annual meeting and
just remove the special
meeting just that i mean it's something
that can take a lot of discussion so it
shouldn't be just a special meeting it
should be at the annual
film
no i think what we ought to do
i i think what we ought to do at this
point in time is that because there is
you know i'm i'm just going back when
you go for school building aid you're
not going to do it with just a majority
vote you've got to have a a larger vote
than that i can't recall was two-thirds
or three-fifths it's one or the other
and um
yeah two-thirds of those present at the
meeting
and so and i have no objections that
either um
i i you know when i wrote this i had
concerns with the idea of a special
meeting as well
um i'm not convinced that that's the way
to travel there this should be at a
regular meeting
one that's people are used to coming to
because it is a huge jump
so i would suggest to you know mr chair
that um we um
just recess any action on on this
particular bill until we can uh
you know
take into account some of the discussion
we've had here
okay
representative woodcock thank you i
appreciate that
i know that representative is moving
this to another venue or another off
time period i appreciate that i do want
to uh if we're going to do some
clarification i'd i would like to uh go
back to what my colleague here to my
left asked about the collective
bargaining agreement when nate green was
here from d.o.e uh without the
information we just had now when he was
here from d.o.e he said 194b14
the collective bargaining group that
that union could not transfer it to the
school they could the charter school or
the new conversion school could have a
union but the union that they came from
is that that is correct that's not what
we just said we could have a union
yes the union they left
is gone they have the style or if they
choose to in the charter school so that
so that unit has been negated it's been
eliminated
um so the dialogue between
representative ellison and ladd uh it
left the the illusion at least to me
anyhow that the union was fine it's not
fine the union is gone
so i just want to make that clear as we
go back into the uh you're gonna we
clarify it again
thank you for the permission to speak
represent cornell representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you for uh
taking my comments
um with regards to the section that
eliminates the faculty and
superintendent and principal from
participating in the decision making
i would be curious as to what the
original legislative intent was of that
because i would venture a guess that
there may have been some concern
that if they
converted a public school into a charter
school
without buy-in from the faculty the
superintendent and the principal
that they might not have a faculty a
superintendent and a principal so
i would
as much as
we can
knock around whether or not teachers are
entitled to
be part of the decision making or
whether they live in the community
i i think we do need to take into
consideration the idea that a school
does not run without a staff
and that we have
teacher shortages there's got to be some
other way of doing this without
eliminating everybody in the school from
being part of the decision making
okay um well
i think that representative porter final
comment
perhaps as we're if we are amending the
bill we could make sure that the staff
and the superintendent and the principal
are involved in the decision-making
process with the school board
and then it goes to a vote
that at least would allow the
faculty to be involved and make a
decision as to whether they want will be
staying with the district or not
okay um so i think we heard that uh we
will recess um this bill to a future
exact session
will be a new amendment is going to be
an amendment worked on to reflect all
this anyone can
work on an amendment it's free to work
on an amendment if they so choose
now one one of the things that there is
a motion on the table yes
um
so would the uh make or the motion so it
would be no i'm not going to take my
motion off the table okay but there
could be an amendment come back that
the the motion of ought to pass
we can't just leave it hanging
well i no you you can we we've had you
know situations before in education
where we've not we've had the most put
on the table but we have not taken
action that particular day
okay we're just recessing yeah so no
vote
right no no vote at this time
yeah
well it's just not you know you just go
just where you've gone
and then and put it in the file just and
okay so uh i'll i'll take over from here
because now we're going on the next bill
and the next one we're jumping over
agriculture in the classroom um we just
had that uh meeting with the
um
the commissioner
last
last after yesterday afternoon
and there were some suggestions came
forward on on some of these one of the
associations to eliminate that and
to so um we're not prepared to do
anything on that right now so we're
jumping over it
and we'll jump to uh charter school fees
11.93
if i could make a motion mr chairman
yes let me get there
okay 1193 relative to charter public
school fees and enrollment policies uh
representative cordell you recognize for
a motion thank you i would like to move
out to pass on house bill 1193 is there
either somebody just okay hops makes the
second
represent cordelia would you like to
speak to your motion
uh thank you mr chairman um
this was brought forward after
discussions with the department of
education
um
based on complaints that they had
received in two areas
one
fees being charged to students
that
could impact
the students ability to enroll
and secondly
an issue with
out of state students being accepted
into border charter schools and
because the charter school was able to
charge tuition to those out of state
students
they were actually
accepting charter students
except out of state charter school
students
that impacted the ability of in-state
students to enroll because of maximum
enrollment
provisions in the charter of the school
so
stating that those fees cannot be
charged as a condition of enrollment
and
secondly that
in-state students have to be given
preference and determination of
enrollment
in the charter school
thank you
does the second have any further
discussion
thank you
it's open to the committee any
discussion from comedian jefferson
woodcock just one i want to reiterate uh
from the discussion we had initially
when
mr green was here that
the phrase enrollment on line four
uh is
initial enrollment and not maintaining
enrollment if you recall my question was
about
supplies in the school and art supplies
and those things so once a student is
admitted without a fee to the program he
can't be removed from the program for
lack of participating
lack of fees at that point
thank you
good point
further discussion
not seeing any uh madam clerk would you
please call the roll
yes this is regarding house bill 1193
relative to chartered public school fees
and enrollment policies the motion is
ought to pass
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative bone yes representative
yes representative moffett yes
representative hobson yes representative
ford
yes representative soti yes
representative nelson
representative luno yes
representative waltz yes
representative tanner yes
representative ellison
representative mullen yes representative
woodcock
representative porter yes
representative hall yes and chairman
ladd yes
okay
next bill we have up is 1202
relative to transportation
of pupils to school activities by a
contract carrier
i recognize representative boom for a
motion
i move
out to pass on
house bill 1202
and is there a second
second
okay
represent boom do you care to speak to
your motion
it's just briefly we had a hearing on
this and
all this removes is the
mileage requirement for the bill we did
last year hasn't we learned we were
arguing over the senate bill and that 75
miles was a round trip or whatever
without thinking ahead
and afterwards we thought of wait a
minute londonderry marching band goes
all over the country
and it's a trip to the airport it's not
75 miles and when i went on a field trip
out of the country we took a coach bus
which is the safest thing to do and it's
not 75 miles so tomorrow's requirement i
don't think it's not required
and
they still can't use it for
any normal transportation like you know
normal school bus trips so it's it's
needed and we found that last year that
the coach buses that we've been using
forever
are were illegal
now that makes last year so i made the
bill legal but just the same as last
year septa miles requirement was removed
thank you is the second cure to make any
uh
nothing further thank you
committee any discussion yes represent
woodcock i just bring this up i was not
here for that meeting i was home with a
uh covered uh
watch um i did watch it on the screen at
the time and last year when the bill
came i questioned the
concern regarding the the background
checks of coach bus drivers for
commercial bus drivers raw students and
the safety exiting for our students
i don't think that has been changed from
last year's bill it wasn't resolved
and i will be voting knowing this bill
rather than that
sure you can ask questions to this
just to representative woodcock i asked
you a question does it he let you does
it he did i asked um
rules follower
does it impact your decision if that
charter driver would not be alone
thank you i wouldn't change my
discussion the the discussion last time
was uh much broader because emergency
access in the building in the school no
practicing with those buses and all
those things so i just think this opens
the door for for more for more
non-certified bus drivers for more uh
non-uh school bus type uh
projections so
thank you thank you for taking my
question
thank you for taking my question and i
this is a question for ref woodcock as
well i was under the impression that we
had legislation
either in process in our committee
dealing with schools and contracted
service
providers that would require them to go
through a background check
did we skip them in all of our work no i
think a representative probably can
clarify it closely with me yelling
across the room because there but we
found last year that when the safety
police came in the state police that the
china bus driver was not under the same
regulatory requirements in terms of
background checks
that our school bus drivers are nor do
they practice with our students on
emergency exits in case of excellence
you get a large bus boom it's over i
mean every school bus the kids practice
once or twice a year before they even
start
thank you
one of the issues that we we had last
year on that was the these
uh commercial
buses
uh which the drivers have gone through
considerable training for and they have
the cdl and all that
um to have the certification that versus
woodcock is talking about if you're on a
trip to washington dc
and your driver all sudden is really
sick in philadelphia
in pennsylvania it's going to be a rare
uh bird that you pick up that has
certification to drive
new hampshire certification
they will have the the cdl and all that
but they won't have that certification
so then the kids are sitting there
and further i mean on these trips field
trips or whatever there are usually a
lot of teachers and chaperones on the
bus also to help with any evacuation and
they're clearly marked on the coach
buses on on evacuations and stuff so
and like i said this has been going on
for
more than 50 years that i know of and
people been doing it so
thank you
okay so we can discuss all the safety
stuff either way on this so the only
change here is 150 miles
and so with that madam clerk would you
please call the the roll
yes this is house bill 1202
relative to transportation of people's
two-school activities by a contract
carrier
the motion on the table is ought to pass
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is a yes
representative bone
representative lakes yes representative
moffett yes representative hobson
yes representative ford
yes representative
yes representative nelson
representative luno yes representative
waltz yes
representative tiana yes representative
ellison
represent mullen yes representative
woodcock
rezab paul yes
and chairman ladd
yes
is there objection to uh consent
represent woodcock
no objection
they really grow independently up there
okay
there won't be a minority report in
there
if it's on consent no
okay
um committee for me uh i better get
right verbiage here
1276 is the bill no 1229
is what we got up on
right next
12 29
we talked a bit about this earlier today
establishing a committee to study school
meal programs in new hampshire's public
schools and non-sectarian schools to
accept public funds
represent hobson do you have a motion
yes i have a motion i would like to move
um
hb 1229 uh to interim study
okay
any discussion from the maker of the
motion
yes we've had quite a bit of discussion
today about the school meal
programs
and schools and whether or not they
participate in addition some of the
other things that we've talked about are
whether or not to use local agriculture
and if if you love farmers the way we do
local products
produce products that help people
feel better
if you grow local honey
you can
have better resistance to um
allergies and things in our in our area
so all of these things i believe should
be studied and maybe even the other
ideas that
um that were brought up in the previous
bills that we itled this morning so i
don't know whose second did but i was
really hoping mullen would
hop on board
okay is there any discussion from the
second
no
any further discussion representative
mullen pick me pick me
um
so is there a
it's more of a question for you mr chair
foresighted enough earlier in the day to
look at this as a vehicle for additional
is this an informal enough process that
the
sponsors of house bill 1657 would just
reach out to representative oregon and
sort of jump on board in a global
interim study or
do we need to do something else to keep
1657 alive as well i think there's been
a lot of discussion on meal plans
breakfast plans the whole nine yards
and i i think there's a wonderful
opportunity here for us to integrate
some of these other bills or discussions
which we've had
as i mentioned that the fourth item
there gave a lot of latitude in this
committee study
so i i have no objection to in fact i
think this interim study is a better a
deal than
you know
at the past then you don't really don't
get on top of that until when it becomes
a committee that's what july or august
and when people get assigned and some of
them probably won't get assigned because
i don't think the committees are being
looked on fondly this way we can have an
interim study but we can also have we
can start working ourselves as a group
of the a study of this committee working
towards
the whole issue of what we've talked
about today i i think it's important
so rated his highest mathematics because
i'm there but you know so what advice
would you have me give representative
simpson
about moving
forward the study of house bill
1657 in terms of this interim study
i i think that the topic which we had
there 1657
was
an itl motion
but i mentioned when we were discussing
it that i felt that it could be
discussed within this area right here i
still hold to that okay
all right yeah fair enough thank you
yes represent tanner
thank you i'm trying to wrap my head
around
how you do an interim study
of a bill for a study committee
that to me it it's like
it just i know it just doesn't sound
like it's it's
it's actually when that's uh
interim study is one where of course it
goes on the
calendar
and then it's you know
i i know i know the what okay
some study is but it just seems
weird to me that you have an interim
study
to study a study committee
um rather than just have a study
committee
that then
picks up these other things and and i
would also back up that you know i i'm
very adamant about the local
family farms and
the whole intent of the bill to include
them
in the uh
you know in the lunch program and in the
schools and i just feel like
if you're studying whether to have a
study committee or not
i'm not sure that that gives you
the opportunity to study
all the things that are really needed in
that one bill the implementation the
different organizations you want to
involve
all that kind of thing so i know
representative hobson's just dying to
go ahead
um no i'm i'm not dying to tell you how
it works but i guess
when i had
when i was thinking about this bill
there are so many different things about
the lunch program and about
what makes
430 public schools able to implement
this why are 30 not
is it a money issue
how much how many meals are kids eating
and what kind of food are they eating
and could we solve supply chain issues
for our schools i mean there was cream
cheese and coffee cup lids a few weeks
ago that we couldn't find
are those products that that we could
replicate um year-round in new hampshire
um and and it helps our economy um you
know rather than so i mean i think
there's just different facets
of all of these things that we could
look at and and that belongs you know
what do we study
committee you know
so
so why don't we just pass a study
committee
rather than pass an interim study of a
study committee
so we the option we have right now
yeah but see if you pass that you're not
going to have a study
because it's going to go through you're
not going to there won't be when are you
law and and when the people are assigned
to it probably
in august
if if then
represent cardelli thank you uh
representative mullen probably will
remember the
hp 581 special ed sub
study committee that we had last fall
um
we didn't get everybody assigned until
um i believe it was the end of september
um and the report had to be out november
1st so we were left with having like
three or four meetings
um when it could have gone much much
longer and that wasn't even an election
year
so i think this year between
as chairman lad said the assignment of
people
the willingness of
the senate and everybody else to pass
this through and even get it signed into
law
and being an election year
i see very little chance of
a study committee actually been able to
do much of a study
that was the case when we had the cte
committee initially we didn't have a
senator on it they just didn't assign we
went ahead and started the job we did
the same thing in the infrastructure uh
committee when we initially started that
we didn't have people assigned but we
got enough people to have a majority
and we went ahead with it we got people
from homeland security it was a
commission and the other departments
3doe and we had our reps we went ahead
the senate's not known for getting
going to kill it if if the bill any kind
of committee
i i'll i'll bet my paycheck here 100
bucks a year 200 i'll bet at all
i bet you we don't get a committee
through the
represent mullen
so
just trying to wrap my head around how
this works so if we were in fact to
interim study
the study committee
because it was in interim study
we could still study
i have set up when i've been chair
before in previous years you know prior
to right after mary gile
we saw areas that we needed to look at
we just did it
we put together a working group and we
did music to my ears mr chairman and so
we just did it that's right a little bit
of that nike stuff just do it yeah okay
thank you
but if it's not an official
excuse me so what has to be official no
no let me finish
my statement please
if it's not an official
committee set up by a piece of
legislation
whatever recommendations it makes
necessarily don't necessarily have to be
looked at by the house
and and acted on by the house it does
official committee right okay so if you
do an ad hoc committee you can do all
sorts that's exactly right and then a
representative or two get together out
of that group and they put legislation
forward and then we got it thank you
there's ways around the bar in a lot of
what different ways so
i see no problem with having a study
going on and we can do that right off if
we can get enough participation amongst
ourselves
this should
the things that have been going through
my head basically have been said by
other members and and it's just
i'm going to vote for this but it's just
weird to me to study the study i write
with representative tanner it's true i
agree with that but you know and what i
was going to suggest is what
representative porter just suggested is
when i was chair i and we had these
things i just set up ad hoc committees
and you're right the the legislature
didn't have to act on it but they did
because it was needed it was an ad hoc
committee we had the committee we had
our
standing committee on board and things
move forward
i i in the end i'm okay with this it's
just a little weird way to do it just
sounds like but you know this is weird
times too it's the first year i've had
you know the second year we've had to
wear these masks there's a lot things
going on 100 and some odd bills we got
you know this is not normal
and so i know let's get the ad hoc stuff
going i did have the same laugh as both
of you when when we talked about it i
said right we're going to have a study
committee to study a committee it does
sound strange but yes it makes sense
mr chair are you assuming that we're
normal anytime
you don't want to hear my answer on that
represent boom let's get on with the
world here yeah just real quick i
remember some years ago we failed we
said no to a study committee on the
house floor yet the following year some
people came in with a bill based on they
had their own study committee so i mean
whether we not i have people can still
study and come up with bills
yes
we have done a lot of influencing
there's another bill that representative
talked about where we've opted to we're
going to send a letter directly to the
commissioner of education
and ask for some work to be done over
there they can do task force and all
that there's a lot of ways getting
things done
and we can if if we can get uh committee
support if you can get an agreement from
your committee here the policy committee
to endorse a letter it's it's
that's the way to do it
and we've done that before too
and and it's always come out with a
positive result
represent we'll put you in charge no
thank you
thank you very much i'll be in charge of
the education committee aspect uh but uh
i'm quite sure that representative
simpson and murray and uh there's a
whole bunch of them that are on this
bill
that have
really done a fine job
connecting with the various stakeholders
in the whole process so i would not want
to do anything without
the they can they
we need to make sure that the working
group we have here is a working group of
people from this committee yeah we can
involve and take input from others
but we got to be careful in that regard
oh yeah and so well and that's what i
meant when i said i'm happy to uh be the
you know the point guard of the house
education aspect of this
but uh they really have a tremendous
amount of knowledge that i think would
be beneficial to
to the word you can be point guard i
hope you watched the best basketball
game ever last night oh i didn't
arkansas beat number one
and it went in overtime
college basketball is where it's at
yeah
okay
she's the point guard you're the
quarterback
that's right i feel like i'm
on the end somewhere right now
uh
no no no 12 29.
yeah uh okay interim study uh bill was
put forth by representing hobson
um so uh
madam clerk will you please call the
roll
yes uh representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes
representative lakis yes
representative moffett yes
representative hobson
yes representative ford
yes representative sodi yes
representative nelson
representative luno yes representative
waltz yes
representative tanner yes
representative ellison
represented mullen
yes representative woodcock
representative porter
representative hall yes
and chairman ladd yes okay 18-0 interim
study
consent any problems
thank you
next bill is 1276 is relative to
including cost per student information
on a school district budgets and warrant
articles
uh
representative uh
hobson or what was that moffitt or
you were awful quiet there's a reptile
thank you mr chair
yes i need to be 1276. uh i'd like to
move uh itl india tango lima
okay
represent hobson do you wanna make a
second on that a second
do you like to speak on your motion talk
uh
briefly sure mr chairman uh this has to
do with the formulas cost per pupil and
the problem that some of us have is that
the
revenues come to districts from various
sources property taxes to be sure but
also grants uh maybe even bonds in some
cases
short-term
one-time covert relief funds are in the
mix suddenly
so the cost per pupil uh ratio or or
formula could be deceptive
um and also the
the cost per student for for example i
think i mentioned this during the
hearing
for the cost per student for a building
roof roof improvement for example
benefits everybody whereas
the cost per pupil on a warrant article
if they break it down for new band
uniforms benefits just like a subset of
students so for those and other reasons
i
involving what i think what some of us
think of
flawed formulas for cost per pupil uh
we're looking for itl
thank you
um
did you make the section i meant no
let's let the second have an okay first
if she cares yeah i do care
but i don't have any further comments so
i will pass it over to alicia
okay i i messed up
i just realized i have an amendment that
was given to me to
introduce on this what we didn't even
talk about and what it does is it clears
up all that
it what it is and everything and it
basically says it's on the operating
budget warrant
so for each warrant item
it would give the cost per pupil for
that warrant item
and so it does change completely all of
those things and i'm sorry i totally
forgot when we were talking about this
so i don't know what you want to do
because
we have a motion on the table yeah do we
want to take it back and
change it and do the amendment
which was put in by rep thomas rep
harley rep moffett and myself
to try to clear up that whole issue
i i don't know if everybody's had the
opportunity to see it exactly you know i
think everybody else was of the opinion
that we would ipl that because his
district verse her district there may be
using all kinds of different elements
and coming up with some kind of a
per-pupil cost
and of course they say it's unto that
district alone but they're going to look
and see over in his district the kids
getting a better education for less
money well that may be so or may not be
so well that was the point of changing
it just to the warrant articles
and so each warrant article
would have what that warrant articles
cost per pupil was
and so if you bundled it all together or
you separated it out it wouldn't matter
because you could look at what the
pieces were
and
you know and they wouldn't be comparable
town to town because it depend upon what
things were on what
well we're just discussing this concept
without any amendment on the floor
there's a lot of elements within a
budget in a small town let's say of 80
kids district
you can have two catastrophic aid kids
in there 250 000 a piece
and that's going to certainly shoot that
budget up but you can't do a darn thing
about it because you're required by law
to do it
uh
so
i i i have some real issues with the
whole thing of this per pupil cost per
warrant article or any any associated
cost so at this point in time i'm not
going to allow the amendment to come
forward
we're going to go ahead with a vote okay
okay
further discussion from the committee on
on that bill anybody
nope
okay um madam clerk will you please call
the roll
yes this is relative to house bill 1276
allowing for school district budgets and
more articles to include cost per
student information the motion on the
table is itl
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes
representative
yes for now
representative moffat yes
representative hobson yes
representative ford yes
representative
yes represent nelson
representative luno yes representative
waltz yes
representative tanner yes representative
ellison
representative mullen yes
representative woodcock
representative porter
representative hall yes and chairman
ladd yes
so that carries 18 to 0.
okay any problems with uh consent
okay the next bill which we had here is
13 55
suspected cases of fraud
and education freedom accounts
i think this is one where we kind of
mike
so rick for discussion purposes why
don't you explain what we got here sure
sure before any motion is before any
emotions being made i'd be happy to
thank you very much for the opportunity
mr chair so 1355
was relative to
the scholarship organization
to refer any suspected cases of misuse
of funds
in the efa program to the attorney
general office and the
the way the current law
is crafted
and it's on line three of the
of the bill is introduced
it uses the word
may so the scholarship organization may
refer suspected cases
of in of intentional and substantial
misuse of efa funds to the attorney
general for investigation and if
evidence of
fraudulent use of efa fronts is obtained
so um so a couple of things have sort of
come to my attention that
that in earlier versions of the efa bill
the word
um the word
the initial word was was shall so the
scholarship organization shall refer
suspected cases rather than may because
you know to be honest the scholarship
organization is in the only position
to even um to even know because they're
the ones reviewing the um the requests
for um for uh for
uh distribution of payment
from the uh the efas
so
the um
so the amendment um uh the amendment
softens
a little bit what uh takes a lighter
touch on 1355.
it um it does replace the word may with
shall
as was
in the in some earlier versions of the
efa
proposals
it um it still takes out into the words
intentional
um but it does restore substantial
and um reason for that is because you
know it's i don't know how you
how how you
uh how a scholarship organization is
going to be able to conduct an
investment conduct an investigation to
know whether or not something was
intentional certainly submitting a form
to request a distribution is intentional
but whether that intent what is that was
an intent of fraud that's really a
question for law enforcement um
department of justice and so that's why
that comes out i put the word
substantial back in
so that these aren't don't become
frivolous type uh you know five cents
here 10 cents there did they use a stamp
on the envelope you know stuff like that
it's got to be substantial
and and substantial is is at least when
uh i think when when we had uh diana
fenton she talked about how that was a
uh um a term of law
and um uh so that's back in there and
then again it takes the uh you know the
it's shall refer suspected cases
substantial use of ef funds to the
attorney general for investigation there
you go that's where the investigation
takes place so you don't need the rest
of evidence because that's what the
attorney general does
so that's the that's the amendment i'd
like to offer representative
yeah just a quick are we being
preliminary on this don't we have
another bill
to put a person in the department of
education to look at efa
really
so wouldn't that so this would say maybe
the department of education but then we
have i don't believe we exact that bill
yet correct no we haven't and that's a
and that's a great question thanks ralph
for bringing that up because um
representative hamm i think brought uh
uh brought that before us and uh
and this would um uh
that
that bill does have some of this
language
in there if both bills pass
that's the language that would that
would um that would rule because it
makes the change not only to the
organization that oversees
the efa but also the shall
[Music]
refer suspected cases of substantial
misuse to the attorney general but if
that
bill fails um
then we don't have anything to fall back
on and i do believe that that it was the
the intent of the the original authors
behind behind efas
to uh
to to
to want to have some mechanism
that that prevents uh fraudulent misuse
or fraudulent use of the money because i
think that that's part of the integrity
um i i got a question for you know the
word intentional how
how do you how do you prove intentional
um you know do we have an attorney in
the crowd here
well that that's that's why the word
intentional is taken i i i i agree with
that and that's what's just saying it's
very difficult for me to understand
whether you're intentionally doing
something or you're just plain doing it
you know
there must be some kind of a fine line
that
attorneys know about that common sense
doesn't
but it's a law enforcement it is a law
enforcement thing i would say
there's no secret fine line it is um
i think what you're looking at at this
point is what would
more be viewed as prosecutorial
discretion and that is as somebody you
know county attorney if it's a criminal
case or a civil case if somebody is
trying to bring this case you know along
the way
they would weigh it and go ah do you
think we can prove it you know and
that's why sometimes things are
convicted or acquitted or found for the
plaintiff or not because it is a fine
line and i think in the end it is the
decision of the judge of the jury
on those close cases i think sometimes
intentional becomes very obvious
people leave paper trails people
talk
not in private you know and you can get
a witness saying ah they told me what
they're doing or you can find a text
trail or an email trailer or something
like that that easily improves intent
i think the short the reason you're
having trouble with it is because i
think
it can be all over the place it can be
anything from very obvious to a very
close call that's going to be up to the
prosecutor or the the attorneys in this
case whether they think they can improve
intent
so um
you know i think
i i like you know i hadn't given this a
whole lot of that but personally i like
this amendment i think
intentional sort of takes that out if
you want and substantial again
substantial is is not exactly a clearly
defined term in the law you know it's
one of those things that i think it
really to a large extent falls back on
the same meaning that you and i think of
with substantial so neither one of those
do i view i mean intent is a term in the
law but the word intentional the word
substantial they are not words that come
to mind to me is being
widely
defined by case law as to what their
meaning is
thank you
president cordelli
a couple of things
they're using a system called class
wallet to monitor expenses and approve
expenses
there are
great many reports out of that system
and i believe that the
intent is to
provide access to that system to the
department and i think that's maybe
where the administrator comes in so they
would have real-time access to view the
transactions and there is much
communication going on
um i know from talking to people in the
department
and the scholarship fund um
uh about questions and um you know about
transactions and so forth so there's a
great
communication
going on in that respect
and
in addition i believe
some of this in terms of
misuse
and reporting
is included in the contract that the
department
had signed by a children's scholarship
i think i've come to the
um thought that
it's really not needed
to
make
this change
and i think
one other aspect is i think some of it
is provided for in
rules that are
going
before
jailcar i think
you know a scholarship organization is
going to have a lot on its plate and
it's not going to be inclined to start
going to look for this kind of stuff
unless we tell them they got to do it
and i think if we don't pass something
like this
it's just going to be overlooked i think
if we really care about how the money's
being used and we really want to protect
the taxpayer we need to be passing
something like this we need to be
telling them yeah this is one of your
responsibilities because if we don't
tell them they're going to be doing
other things and they're just not going
to go looking for this and unless
somebody throws it in their face that
there's been some egregious abuse which
is unlikely to happen
they're not going to pay any attention
as to whether there's a substantial
misuse because they got
like everything else in government too
can i ask you a question uh
the last part which is scratched out
fraudulent use
evidence of fraudulent use
how would that be
gathered
obviously it's
the way it's written there right now i
would
have to have
an understanding that's a fraudulent use
of the efa funds before the
investigation would occur
let me make sure i understand what
you're saying
under the current law or under under the
current law they would have to have
evidence of fraudulent use
of
let me just read it for a moment with
i'm not looking at yours i'm not looking
at chairs i'm looking at what is in the
current 1355.
so
unintentional
evidence of fraudulent so would the
scholarship organization have to come up
use of monies
before the
attorney general
could investigate
i because of the words is obtained i
would argue yes because it says evidence
of fraudulent use is obtained well
how are you going to obtain it if you're
not going out and
you know i suppose somebody could
lay it on you and say you know
somebody's out there and they bought a
new car with their efa money or
something you know like if there was
major abuse of it but
yeah i would say that that
as the law is currently written
i i think i'm i think i'm answering the
question you asked
i think it also goes i mean the the
scholarship organization
is not in a position to make a legal
finding of fraud
that's right i mean that's what the
neither is the
administrator at the efa the new
position at the efa should that go
through
that position is described as a
technical support position
and the job description is described as
being a resource to
parents and
students and the doe and whatever so i
don't know that they've got the legal
wherewithal to be able to
so would this amending language would
this amending language be more
protecting the scholarship organization
yes
i want to comment on the process that
the
organization goes through i'm i'm sure
that
people can figure out how to do just
about anything and somebody might be
able to the only fraud i could think of
here
is
maybe they would sell the stuff instead
of using them but otherwise
the way the process works
you can't get a penny even for a pencil
without first putting in an application
to the scholarship
organization which goes over it which
figures out whether it's appropriate use
etc and then they okay and then you use
that okay to go to a particular provider
and that provider then provides and you
pay for it and you get a receipt and you
send the receipt in and you get
reimbursed and so every single purchase
even a pencil or eraser is personally
okayed by a human being before it's ever
made
so you can't buy a car or a tv or any of
that stuff and not only that the
providers who want to stay providers are
super super careful because they don't
want to lose that business and i will
tell you
that some friends of mine because there
were
a number of children well there were six
children in the program and a number of
them needed new
uh laptops
amazon decided to take away their
ability after these laptops because they
said oh that's too many laptops because
they're thinking of like a kid or two
and not all six kids got laptops but i'm
just saying it was more than the one or
two and
and amazon itself who was one of the
providers for particular things
even though the purchase was okayed even
though everything was done and whatever
amazon itself because they wanted to
stay providers said this looks fishy to
me
and closed and and put a hold on the
account so it will be very very hard for
anybody to commit fraud it be as far as
purchasing the only thing i can think of
is if they then decided to go off and
sell those
sell the things that were gotten
um
and so other than that i mean this whole
idea of buying all these fraudulent
things or whatever it's it it's not
going to happen every single purchase is
reviewed first
and the people have do not have the
money okay they don't get the money they
get the money as a refund
for a purchase that was made or
the money goes straight from the
scholarship organization to the provider
it never
never is in the hands of the actual
parents
they don't get it
represented
thank you
um just
in terms of terminology it doesn't go
from the scholarship organization to the
provider it goes from the uh efa account
to the service provider
and all the transactions are
electronic
um and secondly i know specifically of
an instance
um
two children in the family one with an
efa one wasn't
children's scholarship fund
saw the transaction had questions about
the book
they verified what the age
age-appropriate level was for that book
to find out is this going to the child
with an efa or the child without an efa
so that's the extent of the verification
represent porter
thank you thank you mr chair what
wouldn't you want to just make sure and
protect that organization make sure that
they are checking into potential fraud
if they find it i mean it seems to me
that if you want this program to be
successful you would dread
case coming out in the public of massive
fraud of use of the funds
if even though you say it might not
happen
wouldn't you want to make sure it
couldn't happen by having something like
how would passing a bill keep it from
happening if the scholarship
organization in their own self-interest
is looking to make sure there is no
fraud
then how is passing this bill going to
stop fraud
so so again i think the
the operative word here is words here
misuse of funds fraud is a legal
determination that um that that
currently the um
the scholarship organization is uh is in
the hot seat to have to determine if
evidence of fraudulent use of efa funds
is obtained
um i think this this uh i think the
amendment
i think the bill
and the amendment both clarify that
and and and go right along the lines of
what you're talking about uh alicia that
the scholarship organization has a very
robust very strict
um
misuse detection
system in place
but should something
go awry
should something be uh be be misused
then then the scholarship organization
all you have to do is say look is it
substantial okay
attorney general
you take it the rest of the way take
some out of the hot seat
um to to to determine investigations and
i think it's uh i think this both the
bill and particularly the amendment are
both good looks um at the efa program
for um um granite staters who um who may
be uh
very um
further discussion
representative nelson
thank you this is probably a stupid
question but who's watching who is the
problem watching the scholarship
organization
and their employees is watching the
parent and what they have they're
processing this or how they're involved
in the school who's
what's included i guess i'm confused and
i'm not sure i get the i'm not sure i
understood the question
again i was not at the hearing so we
have to apologize that
i have to apologize for that
we're looking for
suspected cases of
misuse of funds are we watching the
organization that's overseeing the funds
for fraud
or the people who want to get the funds
from them
who are we watching both or just one or
the other so this is specifically that
the scholarship organization
who is is
is uh overseeing or is managing
the distribution of efa dollars
and uh should they see
what um what what is a what what they
suspect may be a misuse of eight uh efa
funds that they report that to the
attorney general for investigation thank
you
thank you mr chair i think an element of
the question that was just asked that
you didn't respond to was what if
someone in the organization is
defrauding the money
someone who's supposed to be overseeing
it finds creates a fictitious creature
funds money to it and collects it right
in their name is that any protection
against that sure sure so the
scholarship organization reports to the
state of new hampshire through a
contract with the um with the with the
governor's office and uh executive
council so that contract um i i
actually i have copies of it i don't
have it memorized right now but i'm sure
there there's there's there's probably
like a lot of contracts have um have
have clauses that uh that contain um
terms that would follow that but that's
a that's a reporting function directly
okay is there a further
discussion
represent tanner
stuck around the corner here um i just
uh you know i i think
from my reading anyway and and
just
i guess to back up whenever there's a
large amount of money
floating around it seems like there's
always the potential for fraud
and i think the people that
commit fraud uh or try to or seize that
opportunity
you know kind of go out and seek it and
we've seen it happen in other states i
mean even individually you're not exempt
from
having something fraudulently you know
your id stolen or whatever particularly
when you're interacting over the
internet so i just think this is like a
protection
um it's a protective statement
and um i think it you know it's it's
kind of like an insurance uh that we're
going to have
some backup
um
because
you know things like that are just part
of our
culture now i think
okay i think there's been enough
discussion on this what i'm going to do
is
i'm not going to take action on this one
today
um this has been introduced and i think
it's generated
all our
wheels and gears up here to start you
know moving
and i myself right now i'm having a
difficult time
um
with the
with
what we've got here and which is the
path to take
so
we'll recess this one there's not
there's nothing on the table right now
other than discussion which we've had so
even take it home and sleep on a little
bit maybe we can get this on the docket
again tomorrow you know rick since it's
since it's not an early bill i might
suggest uh we consider it back-to-back
when bonnie ham's uh bill comes to exec
yeah yeah
exactly where ralph was what's the
so anyways i think what we will do is
let's jump over that quickly and take
care of a couple that i know we can do
um
the next one
um centralized criminal records check
1398.
uh
it's one you're
yeah
yeah 1398 establishing committee to
study the feasibility of centralized
criminal history records checks in
education and carol mcguire came in here
and they've had some discussion on the
jail card level as well
so i'll recognize at this time uh
represent
like us
for a motion i'd like to move this oto
please i mean otp please
otf otl i'm confused
i think so
okay um
and is there a second for ought to pass
on the centralized criminal records
check
that was foreign
okay any further discussion from the
maker
yes since we have seen this many times
and it's
been an issue on many bills we've been
trying to do and various people in here
have worked on this before on
subcommittees and study things and
whatever
we know that it's something that we need
to take care of but we also know that
it's extremely complicated when we first
went to do it it was like oh piece of
cake and then the more we looked the
more we found that this conflicts with
that and this needs these permissions
and so it would be nice to do have an
actual
committee to
study all the ins and outs and get all
the appropriate people there the safety
people and the administrative people and
the education people and see if we can
for once and for all actually
come up with something that will work
maybe we can't but at least this will
give us the best attempt
represent porter do you have anything to
add
heard me
i didn't know if you had that on i
couldn't hear you i said i agreed with
her oh okay great thank you is there any
further discussion then madam clerk will
um
yeah
i i i think it's going to be okay i
think
okay so this is a vote on house bill
establishing a committee to study the
feasibility of centralized criminal
history records checks in education
the uh motion is ought to pass
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes
representative lacas yes
representative moffett yes
representative hobson
yes representative oliver
yes representative sodi yes
representative nelson
representative luno yes
representative waltz yes
representative tanner yes
representative mullen
yes
represent woodcock
from porter yes
represent hall yes
and chairman ladd yes
okay ought to pass 17-0 okay thank you
for me
yeah is that consent
you i will we'll find out um
and we also have uh
carol is also a chair of gel car
um
well
i've been on that one
okay let's try to squeeze one more in
here
the next one
uh transportation to a charter uh
charter school 1453 no wait a minute
that's
okay
okay um
i initially had uh representative
cornell down to make that motion but
yeah
um
that's
okay
is there a second
and
the maker of the motion
the maker of the blurb do you have
anything to say
um
i guess a couple things one was that it
seems like a really complicated issue
that needs to be sorted out a little bit
more
um and i know at least from up in my
area where every student is bused to
curasarge regional high school
that um
some of the requests in this this bill
made it um virtually impossible to
to do it in an effective efficient and
manner so
okay
um let's see uh reps and hops do you
have anything to say
okay reversing wall
i just want to say i heard from
representative cornell and they have no
transfer stations in boston i mean
boston and manchester i'm sorry it is
almost time to go home in it
in manchester so
i'm not even sure that this is really
going on but apparently it's not going
out of manchester if it was going on
anywhere you'd think that would be where
it was yeah
yeah
is there any further discussion
not seeing any uh madam clerk will you
call the rule please
yes thank you this is regarding house
bill 1453 relative to transportation
toward chartered public school
the motion on the table is itl
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes representative
lakes yes represent moffitt yes
representative hobson yes representative
ford yes representative soti yes
representative nelson
representative luno yes representative
waltz yes representative tanner yes
representative ellison
represent mullen yes represent woodcock
represent porter
representative hall yes and chairman
eight eighteen to zero
eighteen to zero i'm sorry yeah
that's right
and consent
okay i think we're going to call it
quits right there we're all getting a
little uh
shaky here
and
shakey's a nice easy term identified as
at least nobody's bungling names
mr chair
at least no one's bungling names like
yesterday
oh
well i've done it before myself
yeah i want to look at these because i'm
going to get copies
8 9 10 11 12 13
yeah oh yeah
well judiciary the other day did 41.
wow
that's exactly right yeah yeah
yeah
and they they said they took up easy
ones too
so
[Music]
oh we only did 15 i got yeah
okay that that's right yeah
so do you want these but these committee
reports by tomorrow morning by tomorrow
morning yes yes
and your committee reports just try to
email them to me
because i gotta review them before
and then given lindsay lindsey gives
them to jen jen reviews them up there
then they go on and they keep getting
reviewed they're gonna come from mel and
me they're gonna send them to me that's
fine too as long as i get them so i can
because tomorrow we're gonna have to
make sure
the early bills are absolutely done and
do you have the uh bill on the
foundation budget the blurb i do
yes i am in fact it's already been
written
good
you